hello street talkers and welcome back to
the show this is
a special edition i've been dreaming
about this show for what seems like
nearly a year now
i first read kenneth's book about a year
ago
but anyway i hope you enjoy the episode
i'm just sat here sipping a vita coco
coconut water
okay let's go to achieve your highest
goals you have to be willing to abandon
[Music]
them
we have a nose for the interesting
that's how we got this far that's how
civilization came out
that's why the history of innovation is
so amazing
everything washes out when we start
ruling by committee
like we have to allow people to follow
their passions to their extremes and yet
we run society
as if this actually makes any sense at
all i think the gradient of
interestingness
is probably the best expression of like
the ideal divergent search
you get to this problem that like i
don't know how to formalize
interestingness
what you get to then are proxies for
interestingness that not everything
that's novel is interesting
but just about everything that's
interesting is novel it is in my
personality in nature
to want to overthrow this i guess we
could say
tyranny of objectives okay a little bit
of housekeeping before we kick off i
just want to make it super clear what
the structure of this podcast is so
for the first hour and 15 minutes or so
i am introducing
kenneth stanley's ideas i'm talking
about open-endedness
i'm talking about novelty search and
abandoning objectives
and pick breeder and the neat algorithm
the neural evolution
of augmenting topologies algorithm so if
this is interesting to you
then um you know feel free to watch the
introduction one thing that people have
commented on is that sometimes in our
shows we have been using clips from the
main show in the introduction and you
felt like
we were showing you the same thing twice
that hasn't happened i haven't showed
anything at all
in the main show in the introduction
it's all fresh content
but if you do just want to skip straight
forward to the interview with kenneth
and feel free to do that we've got the
table of contents just skip on
and it's it's about an hour 15 minutes
in anyway enjoy the show
[Music]
me
professor kenneth stanley is one of my
heroes
of artificial intelligence my particular
area of
interest and research has been in what's
called neuroevolution which is a
combination of neural networks and
evolutionary computation
so i'm saying we got to flip this
completely like the smart part is the
exploration
the dumb part is the objective part
because it's freaking easy
i personally think that kenneth's area
of research which is
neural evolution and ai generating
algorithms
and open-endedness are the most
promising paradigms
in ai research i don't really get this
excited about many other areas of ai
research
apart from perhaps francois charles's
neural program search which is actually
quite related conceptually
there's nothing really insightful or
interesting about just doing objective
optimization yeah we've got plenty of
good algorithms for doing that and it's
not
counter-intuitive at all it totally
makes sense but it's not going to get us
hardly anywhere interesting whatsoever
so today we have an incredible
conversation with professor stanley
and as you can see he really enjoyed
being on the show too this was this was
a great time it's one of my favorite
experiences
of any show so thanks for having me on
it's really an honor to be here dr keith
duggar being the wonderful character
that he is
provided a robust rebuttal to many of
the ideas in kenneth's book and
actually it turned into a really
interesting back and forth and
turned on her up please keith is
actually quite critical of kenneth's
work
i forced keith to read kenneth's book in
about june of last year and and uh yeah
he was quite critical of it we discussed
the chapter seven on education
back in september on our episode in
capsule networks
i'm gonna have this objective where we
give you this test and we see how many
numbers you can add together and in 30
minutes and then based off of that we're
gonna hire the top
whatever 20 percent would we be
complaining
if their instructors and teachers were
manipulating them to perform better and
better on that exam
no because they're actually just causing
them to perform better and better at the
actual job
that they're gonna that they're gonna do
so the objective is very closely tied to
what they actually need to do to be
productive or what society needs them to
do for
some particular application great
manipulate away
nobody's saying to silence diversity
people are saying that a combination
of let's call it novelty search plus
objective optimization is the way to go
the reason i'm showing you that clip is
that there is going to be a clash of
views on this podcast right
kenneth is a great sport for coming on
this show and debating keith
in this way if i was kenneth i would not
have come on the show
you know keith can be a bit of an animal
so anyway i hope it will make the show
more exciting for you folks
and kenneth really is a good sport for
coming on so yeah
my kudos to uh to kenneth interesting
okay
which are some of the key areas that
kenneth stanley thinks that we need to
explore
to develop artificial general
intelligence divergence
as opposed to our current obsession with
convergent algorithms
populations as opposed to putting all
your eggs in a single basket
diversity preservation stepping stone
collection though we know not where
those stepping stones may lead
generating new solutions and new
problems at the same time
in the same run so kenneth and his
co-author joe lemon
penned this book why greatness cannot be
planned
i really recommend that you read the
book i read it myself last may and
it's one of the few books that i've read
in my life where
i've really kind of changed my opinion
on some of my outlook
um i've been around the sun quite a few
times now and i've
converged in so many different aspects
of my thinking but
this book really was a kind of a wake-up
call for me it caused a real stir in my
thinking it's a short book
you can read it very quickly and i
recommend that you do
we actually wrote a book called why
greatness cannot be planned um
it's not even about just computer
science granting agencies are based on
objective criteria they say
the first thing they want to know is
define your objectives tell us how
you're going to get there we'll evaluate
your grant and whether we're going to
give you money
based on the likelihood that this is
going to work like how terrible is that
when
we now understand that sometimes the
best way to actually get innovation
is to not follow the objective gradient
so this is just totally ridiculous the
way we're running things in our society
and there's so many things in your life
that are objectively driven
it's like any time you do anything
someone says well what are you trying to
accomplish what will you accomplish what
is the payoff going to be why are you
doing this
like from the moment you choose your
major or even where you're going to go
to school and so on throughout your
entire life
now is it possible to explore
a search space intelligently without
using an objective
to align ourselves towards discovery and
away
from the trap of preconceived results
kenneth thinks that
greatness is possible if we're willing
to stop demanding
what that greatness should look like
why are the greatest moments and
epiphanies in our lives
often unexpected serendipitous
and unplanned nearly two-thirds of
adults attribute some aspect of their
career choice
to serendipity because the stepping
stones that lead
to the greatest outcomes are unknown
not trying to find something can often
lead
to the most exciting discoveries
youtube was first envisioned as a video
dating site
flickr was part of an online social game
inspired by a pet game to arrive
somewhere remarkable
we must be willing to hold many paths
open
without knowing where they might lead
one of the things which we'll get more
into today is natural evolution itself
and what human innovation looks like
because both of those processes they
proceed without any final objective
natural evolution it didn't solve a
problem
it solved innumerable problems and it
continues to solve new problems so what
do i mean by problem like i mean
the problem of flight the problem of
photosynthesis the problem of
human level cognition like all of these
things were invented
in the same run objectives provide a
powerful security blanket
they seem to protect us from unknowns
but our world has become so saturated
with objectives
kenneth says that objectives are good
when they're modest
but not so if they are ambitious that is
to say if they entail
discovery creativity invention
innovation or happiness kenneth thinks
that
objectives distract us from our passions
or for the correct stepping stones in
our lives that we should be taking
they've become a pillar of our culture
but they're also
a prison around our potential how many
children do you know
who formulate an objective before they
go out to play
how many great scientists really
formulated a hypothesis
before their great idea do you ever tell
yourself that you can't do something
because it's not justified by a clear
purpose
have you ever been told to get your head
out of the clouds
there is a tyranny of objectives out
there in the world
we rarely talk about the dominance of
objectives in our culture
even though they impact us from the very
beginning
of our lives objectives dominate our
lives at work
in a lot of professions the first
question you'll hear if you propose a
new project
is what's the objective i've got a
brilliant idea
why don't we try and increase the levels
of group think at work
we should start with technical design
reviews and then we should
do best practices where every single
step of the process is mandated and
signed off with stakeholders
and then all of the code that we write
must have peer review
as well um i really think that this will
all
unify our minds and objectify
everything that we're doing at work by
the way i'm slightly guilty of this
myself
but we need to be able to take the piss
out of ourselves a little bit don't we
and this is what kenneth meant about
ambitious objectives
if you're a stepping stone away if i
mean this sort of the way we put it in
the book
then by all means use objectives we've
created a culture in the field of
artificial intelligence and machine
learning
where everything has to be evaluated in
order for us to make progress
so i can't submit it to a conference if
i don't have a very concrete evaluation
metric that's very objective
what we may have to do is to acknowledge
that some things are actually subjective
we're talking about creativity
ultimately it is in the eye of the
beholder i could argue with you
actually that everything in nature is
not interesting it's just a matter of
opinion i find it interesting
there's no objective proof that
everything is interesting including us
but we've accepted that it's interesting
we accept that intelligence is
interesting you know why are we all
pursuing it
and so ultimately like creativity
is partially a subjective matter and
yeah there's some interaction between
our subjective
view of the kinds of things that we find
interesting and some
like modicum of objectivity which is
sufficient at least
to present to you an experiment and
that's something we're very
uncomfortable with like we want it to be
entirely objective
so you may have to grapple with that in
order to actually start to really
flourish with creative systems
why should we have to justify what's
interesting to us we let people spend 30
years of their lives getting up to phd
level
developing a nose for what's interesting
developing strong intuitions
we still don't trust them we use
significance calculations to prove that
people are doing the wrong thing
we ask them to provide us with lots of
metrics and key performance indicators
of how they're doing
you know these metrics basically stop
people from using their education
intuitions are banned any kind of
subjectivity is
distrusted this is completely the wrong
direction we should actually be thinking
about
opening up playgrounds this is where
real innovation happens
we view animals through the lens of
survival and reproduction
evolution's assumed objective
people often say that a pursuit is not
well defined enough
if it doesn't have an objective the
process of setting an objective
attempting to achieve it and measuring
progress along the way
has become the primary route to
achievement in our culture
do increasing test scores lead to
subject
mastery is the key to artificial
intelligence
even related to intelligence itself
does taking a job with a higher salary
bring you closer
to being a millionaire if you start
trying to do things that are really
ambitious you'll run into it
um you know like you might say well okay
my goal is to be a billionaire or
something okay well
now let's measure every decision you
make against whether it actually
increases your salary
and then think about whether that's
going to lead you to becoming a
billionaire i mean almost certainly not
because
the gradient you should be following to
get to be a billionaire is probably
orthogonal to your salary it's
nothing to do with that like even if you
double your salary it has nothing to do
with whether you're going to be a
billionaire
and we get caught in these paradoxes all
the time including objective functions
in machine learning
but also this may be a key uh step on
the path to artificial intelligence you
know when you think about it
intelligence is one of those so far off
goals
you know like the kind of like trying to
make a billion dollars kind of a thing
farther than that for sure because
people actually do that um
that like it is one of those things
where it's totally unclear what the path
should be
let's talk about the chinese finger trap
the finger trap is a simple puzzle
that traps the victim's fingers often
the index fingers
in both ends of a small cylinder woven
from bamboo
the initial reaction of the victim is to
pull their fingers outwards
but this only tightens the trap the way
to escape the trap
is actually to push the ends towards the
middle
the complete opposite of your intuitions
which enlarges the openings and frees
the fingers
this is a great metaphor for what we're
talking about here right because the
solution is deceptive
you need to do the opposite of your
intuition in order to escape
from the trap campbell's law which is
well known in the social sciences
says that the more any quantitative
social indicator is used for social
decision making
the more subject it will be to
corruption pressures and the more apt it
will be to
distort and corrupt the social processes
it is intended to monitor
in other words social indicators like
academic achievement tests
are least effective exactly when the
objective
is to bring them higher the economy
could be stuck in a chinese finger trap
right a decrease might be needed to
provide a larger increase in the economy
later we might need to see the nhs fail
or get worse in order for it to get
better the mistake objectives make is
assuming that there's a
monolithic trace through their values
between now and some good future states
sometimes things need to get a little
bit worse before they get
better there's this notion at the moment
that whether it's profit or educational
or scientific achievement
that it must increase monotonically
every single year
and that is deception so objectives
can create perverse incentives campaigns
aimed at reducing alcohol abuse or drugs
can actually result in
more dangerous drugs being used instead
when india was under british rule
the british government tried to
exterminate venomous snakes by
paying citizens for every dead snake
they handed over
but it didn't work the way it was
intended instead
it led to citizens literally breeding
cobras
just to kill them for the bounty
which is incredible right so ultimately
the number of venomous snakes in india
increased as a result of attempts to
decrease it
many in the uk will remember that
objectives took the uk by storm in tony
blair's government we
had lots of performance metrics around
waiting lists and
the number of hospital beds that were
required and
of course people would just game the
metrics they would just
take the wheels off the trolley beds so
that they counted as extra beds
it completely distorts the system and
unfortunately
it removes any intrinsic motivation for
people to perform better at work
objectives can be tyrannical like the
interesting things are actually at the
high level not the low level
like what are the incentives that
actually help something to like move in
the direction of learning the thing i
wanted to learn
um and everybody has intuitions about
incentives in education as well
teachers should be allowed more autonomy
to follow their battle tested instincts
about which methods foster deep learning
and understanding of the materials and
obviously i mean
the other type of deep learning the real
the real one
um but the lesson is that silencing
diversity
um and divergence of approach is a
surefire way
to slow down progress and i mean
diversity of thought
deception is a concept in search
but it's also just a general concept in
life but it's maybe not recognized how
serious the problem is
in other words you're following a path
where some performance metric is going
up
but you're actually going in the wrong
direction this happens all the time it's
called deception
it happens in machine learning too and
so it leads to what's called like local
optima and people know about this
but what people didn't really recognize
and appreciate is just how profound
deception is
stepping stones are important the path
to greatness is actually
unknown stepping stones are portals to
the next
level of possibility and we have to find
these stepping stones
if you're a freshman in college there
may be a path to making a million
dollars before you reach 30
but what you should do first is probably
not so obvious in other words you have
to search for the right stepping stones
and if you're lucky and clever enough
you might discover the ones
that lead to the objective there may be
a number of stepping stones you have to
cross
and many of them are likely challenging
to figure out
stepping stones which lead to ambitious
objectives
tend to be pretty strange in the sense
that
they don't resemble the final end state
at all
for example vacuum tubes led to
computers
few saw that one coming microwave ovens
came from radar technology it was a
lucky accident when percy spencer first
noticed the magnetron melted a chocolate
bar in his pocket in 1946
the internal combustion engine led to
aeroplanes
you see the thing is creativity itself
is a search
problem if we're searching for objective
then we must be searching
through something the space of all
possible things in a sense
the places that we visited whether it's
in our lives or in our minds
are stepping stones to new ideas
one of the key concepts in this paradigm
of search
is deception the measures we use to help
us search
actually blind us to the stepping stones
we should actually
take which is to say quite clearly
objectives
themselves block discovery
it's almost impossible to shortcut the
process of innovation
take human intelligence for example we
know
that single-celled organisms did evolve
over billions of years
into human beings so all you need to do
is accelerate this process right so
just select parents that look
increasingly human
and voila you've done it before you know
it right you've just created
humans but you'd be wrong
so wrong your pants are on fire in fact
i think it wouldn't work if that was
what you were trying to do whatever that
would mean like for example like if we
started evolution on earth with
a single cell where presumably it
started and we said all right let's get
human level intelligence let's start
let's let's start working on this so
let's give them iq tests you know like
we're gonna we're gonna just go straight
to let's go straight to the heart of the
matter let's not go through all these
silly things like flatworms and stuff
like that well i mean that wouldn't work
obviously
the colony would die when you start
throwing it at a iq test
just ridiculous the problem is that the
stepping stones to intelligence
do not resemble intelligence put another
way
human level intelligence is a deceptive
objective
for evolution millions of years ago our
ancestor was a flatworm
it wouldn't score any accolades for its
intellect i can tell you that for now
but
its one great achievement was its
bilateral symmetry
the stepping stones closest to the shore
fade gradually
as they wind into the fog you come upon
a fork
where a choice must be made because of
the fog you don't know where the path
leads
even though the mind is a powerful force
in searching it's still difficult to see
further than one stepping stone away no
matter how intelligent you are
we think it's always best to take the
road that heads in the direction of your
desired destination
but when the objective function is a
false compass
it's called deception which is a
fundamental problem in search and in
machine learning because
what what do machine learning algorithms
do right they basically just take a
gradient
of the direction that we're optimizing
in and they go in that direction so
these algorithms they suffer terribly
from this false compass
in a way it's a similar concept that
some of you folks might be aware of
which is the exploration versus
exploitation trade-off
in reinforcement learning but of course
kenneth stanley is talking about
something completely different
he sees that kind of exploration as
basically a complete waste of time it's
just a random
a random search which isn't really
guided by any notion of interestingness
in gpth3 we do a greedy search right for
every next token that we're predicting
we have a probability distribution and
we just
greedily take the ones that appear
highest probability now
but probably we trace a path which will
give us cycles or give up give us
things which are completely crazy
because we don't have
that view into the fog so to speak this
is what deception is
okay so let's look at an example of
deception so
we're in a maze we're an agent we take
actions in an environment there's a
state action space and let's say we need
to learn some policy
using some kind of algorithm now kenneth
would argue that
almost every single problem has
deception and the deception is quite
simply this
i have some kind of a reward which i'm
trying to optimize on monotonically and
that reward is my distance to the goal
state so clearly
i hit a wall i can't intersect the wall
i can't go any closer
and now in order for me to reach the
real goal state i need to
actually make my reward look worse for a
significant amount of time
now currently we use things like
exploration and exploitation to solve
these problems
but kenneth would argue that exploration
is convergent it doesn't really
have any kind of gradient of
interestingness so in kenneth's work
essentially he relies on this concept of
novelty search because novelty is is a
proxy for interestingness
and novelty is an information
accumulator which you can directly
optimize on
but you know the key concept we want to
get across here is that there is more to
deception than just the structure of the
maze
the search space is not actually the
maze itself right the search space is
the uh
the space of neural network topologies
underneath
inside your model would it be possible
for us to define a notion of what
interestingness or
curiosity actually is it's clear that
curiosity is
is fundamental to early development and
learning
and and becoming intelligent as a human
is
it's not clear how to actually formalize
or
motivate curious behavior because it's
not really clear how to formalize what's
interesting
and so i don't always think of it in
terms of an objective okay now the kid
has a new objective jump on a log and
now the kid has an objective
to play with that doorknob or something
like that so much as
the kid has some notion that certain
things are interesting and it's like a
very
perceptive notion somehow and we all
have this
but it's different in all of us too
we're not all we don't all agree on
what's interesting
and so if we want to have curious
systems at all the different range of
human intelligence from like a baby up
to an adult
like a mature expert in some field we
have to grapple with this very
subjective notion of what is interesting
and that means that we have to grapple
with subjectivity
which we don't like as scientists like
benchmarks and stuff we like being very
objective about where we're trying to go
and so to deal with subjectivity it
means that
at the ground below a lot of our
assumptions are going to be something
that
that can't be motivated objectively
something that is ultimately just
something that we believe
and we have to somehow figure out how to
get the ai to align with that because if
we just say go off and do things that
are
novel in some completely undefined way a
generic way
then um it'll go deviate off into a
space that we don't find interesting
how do we align that notion with the
things that we actually find interesting
so that it can plunder the space that we
want to
exist within and so what does that mean
i guess it means that there are things
that
we have the capacity to do as
individuals and together
that that we we need help to do but we
can't do without some help
for example i know great art when i see
it but i can't produce great art i know
great music when i hear it
and somehow these kind of latent
capabilities that we have
maybe could be made more explicit if we
had the right kind of assistance
and so in some way i think that what ai
can do and would be really exciting if
it would do is just amplify
us in our capabilities and give us the
ability to express
ourselves so kenneth has pioneered this
field of open-endedness in artificial
intelligence
what exactly do we mean when we talk
about open-endedness
open-endedness is not how to learn
something like how to learn how to do
some particular task so rather it's
really you can think of it as how to
learn
everything there are properties of
evolution evolution in nature
that are just so profoundly powerful and
are not explained algorithmically yet
because we cannot create phenomena like
have been created in nature
if you think about something like the
history of all of human invention
now that is beyond interesting and that
is in some sense an algorithmic process
a process that continually
increases in diversity and complexity
without bound virtually forever
in fact there are a number of different
kinds of open-ended processes that we
can observe in nature
there's the process of human innovation
which i'm alluding to but also like
natural evolution for example which is
not human driven that's also an
open-ended process
it's the ongoing creation of all the
diversity of life on earth
so if you think about open-ended
processes they're not about like a
single positive result
it's really not about any particular
result at all it's really about surprise
like an ongoing cacophony of surprises
as we tried to argue there's a parallel
between our own
history of innovation and evolution i
think we're gonna continue to pursue
these kind of algorithms and also
hybridize them
with others including learning
algorithms because after all that is
the world in which we live where there's
an outer loop of evolution and inner
loops of learning
this is the tree of life and this is a
single run
so to speak of an algorithm called
evolution which generated
all of life on earth this is quite
incredible so the process itself is is a
process of endless surprises we can't
really predict where it's going to be
going in the future
and we couldn't have predicted where it
has been and look at the kinds of things
that it produces along the way like it
invented all these things like it
invented photosynthesis
and invented the flight of birds it
invented
of course intelligence itself all in one
single run
to get to these really really far away
branches of the tree of life
you cannot have an optimization process
you have to have an open-ended process
but those branches are worth getting to
and
what's interesting is we don't have an
algorithm like that including an
evolutionary computation
it's not something that invents one
thing it's something that invents
everything
this is not only an explanation for our
actual existence
because it perceived us and created us
but it also seems deeply entrenched in
our nature we don't actually know what
is the property of our universe
that has facilitated something that
could go on for more than a billion
years of creativity
you could come back a billion years
later and still be surprised at what
it's creating
we don't create systems like this like
none of the domains or artificial
systems we create have this property
so you're just putting algorithms aside
for a second
this is a fertile area for research to
understand open-ended environments
where the surface is still barely
scratched
to understand human level intelligence
we are going to need to understand
creativity that's a big part
of what being intelligent means from a
human level
is our creative aspect we may need
to implement and run some kind of
creative process or open-ended process
that produces
this general intelligence we may not be
able to get to
this really high level of intelligence
without some kind of process that's
creative generating the intelligence
itself
what kind of process explains
open-endedness and complexity explosions
like things where things just keep on
getting more and more complex
up to really an astronomical level like
the human brain with its
100 trillion connections one of the most
important ingredients
is divergence it's really important
because a lot of the time we're worrying
about convergence all the time
converging towards the optimum
converging towards the objective
minimizing this loss but but if it isn't
but for open-endedness if it's important
to get divergence then a lot of our
intuitions that we've been building up
are not relevant to that kind of a
process because divergence is like the
opposite of convergence
the system has to generate the problems
and the solutions and they have to be
self-generating
since no one can anticipate a curriculum
all the way up through a billion years
it's the system's job itself to generate
that curriculum
and this is the key to earth's
open-ended creativity it's generating
both the problems and the solutions
and that's an interesting thought
because where are the problems
coming from that we're solving well
they're coming from each other
the thing is we are both the problems
and the solutions like we as the
organisms that are being evolved
because the existence of anything
creates the opportunity for something
else
like the existence of trees now makes it
possible for us to have giraffes and
giraffes are solving a problem
but the problem was actually created by
the trees which is how do you get to the
leaves of the trees when they're high up
and so all of us are creating or maybe i
shouldn't even call it problem
opportunities for each other the fact
that i'm standing up here gives you an
opportunity to learn something but also
the fact that you're in the audience
give me the opportunity to talk to you
and so forth
and so we're all creating opportunities
for each other all the time and that is
the source of why this process can go
forever
and we really would love to produce a
truly open-ended algorithm
and the space of problems is a lot
different from the space of solutions
isn't it like the space of solutions is
we've been grappling with that for a
long time and
like deep learning is all about a space
of solutions they happen to be in neural
network space it's a neural network
space but the space of problems is much
harder to understand then how do you
represent problems as opposed to
solutions
and what keeps them interesting and
meaningful forever
perhaps to achieve human level ai we
must travel the road with no destination
there are many destinations that are
reachable through no other process
than not trying to reach them and
therefore we have to confront the grand
challenge of open-endedness and i want
to highlight that grand challenge of
openness i believe this is a challenge
just as worthy as ai of huge amounts of
resources if we could conquer
open-endedness and create algorithms
that create forever we will have opened
up a massive sphere of possibilities
that's currently not available to us
the power of creation is the power of
open-endedness so
technically this all started with
yannick light speed culture in icml 2019
yannick went to their tutorial you know
we've got kenneth stanley and joel
layman talking about open-endedness and
poet etc
and it inspired yannick to make a video
on it on his youtube channel which was
quite nascent back in summer of 2019
we're not actually talking about an
optimization problem
because there's not a particular problem
that we're trying to solve rather we're
trying we're inventing problems and
solving them
at all times and there's not anything
specifically that we're trying to solve
the less you have an objective so you
can kind of think about that like if you
have millions and millions of objectives
you imagine millions of people with
different objectives
the whole system in aggregate starts to
be less objective
i was kicking myself actually because
annoyingly i didn't meet yannick at
icml19 even though we were both staying
in the western hotel
but yeah i would have found that
absolutely fascinating and uh
fortunately i i found out about it
vicariously later through connor shorten
and obviously meeting yannick this is
what yannick had to say at the time so i
was pleasantly surprised by this
tutorial
because i knew almost nothing about
these techniques
and they seem really cool seems to be a
really cool line of research
so started out with what is population
based
search and basically in population based
search you don't want to just reach
one solution of a problem but you want
to kind of maintain a
population of solutions that you
develop over time so this is jeff cloone
presenting at icml 2019. now jeff cloon
is incredibly well known in the
open-endedness literature and
if you haven't checked out his work make
sure you do he's a great guy
so our most recent algorithm here is
this poet algorithm which
stands for the paired open-ended
trailblazer and there is a pair
of things happening there's going to be
an algorithm that's generating problems
or challenges or training environments
an observation they make is if you look
at nature
and natural evolution it is very
successful
even without a goal so there's no goal
in mind to
natural evolution except reproduction
creates other reproduction but is not a
goal that's um
that's simply a kind of underlying
mechanism
what if we build a search algorithm that
only wants to create novel things
so where kind of novelty is the only
goal
uh what happens then this is a clip from
our first ever episode of machine
learning street tour we were so excited
about this
connor shorten recommended that we check
out this poet paper
the uh pairwise open-ended trailblazer
we're going to talk about
uber's recent paper the enhanced poet
open-ended reinforcement learning
through unbounded invention of learning
challenges and their solutions
by wang itau now this paper it
introduces a new paradigm of machine
learning
which is called ai generating algorithms
or open-endedness
it's all one single run of the same
algorithm
and it doesn't really have a goal in
mind so
open-ended algorithms are like that they
kind of define an
interesting notion is it still
interesting if we were to just let it
run for a billion years
like would it still be interesting if
yes consider it an open-ended algorithm
you might even be asking yourself why
should we be looking at population-based
methods to learn
let's say uh policies instead of
reinforcement learning algorithms
the reason they're not as well known is
because they are population-based
methods and traditional machine learning
community does not
deal with populations of agents but a
single agent trying to solve a task
but we think that the ideas and the
algorithms and the insights behind them
are very broadly applicable
what is the difference between the
problems that evolution is better on and
in the problems that the deeper l is
better on
in terms of surprising results probably
the most
shocking result that we found was that
there were a few games where random
search so not a ga
just complete a random search in this
huge high dimensional network space
uh was actually better than than some
very good well-respected deep
reinforcement learning algorithms
okay like we already know all about
evolutionary algorithms
you would have learned them in your
computer science degree it seems like
we've already got this problem nailed
right
wrong and we also tried to propose some
enhancements
uh to to like modern kinds of
evolutionary algorithms that like sort
of
protect them from some of their
criticisms about evolution like for
example that
well mutation is completely random so
it's unprincipled compared to sgd which
is actually
looking at the gradient and following
that in some kind of principled way
so we introduced like new kinds of
mutation operators that actually are
gradient informed mutation operators so
it's kind of mixing paradigms in a way
to make the point that you know when we
criticize evolutionary algorithms
because like say it's just random or
something like that it's kind of a
myopic view
the main thing that current genetic
algorithms do not have
is divergence what they do have is
diversity
they maintain a separate population of
individuals and then they do crossover
and
random mutation and all that good stuff
but the fascinating thing about real
evolution is divergence
and one characteristic of that is that
evolution is continuously
providing new problems and solutions to
help agents if you like maximally
exploit the environment that
that we're in so divergence is super
important and then you might think well
does that
imply that gas now are convergent
yes they are and one of the main reasons
they converge is because they have one
fixed objective
which means if you run it for a
significant amount of or not
maybe not even a significant amount of
time if you run it it will converge
on a kind of local optimum and then
that's it it will no longer continue to
improve
there's something wrong here because
evolutionary algorithms what are just
talking about here they also converge
they converge and then they basically
give you your solution or they get stuck
like any other machine learning
algorithm and then that's the end
and it basically by the way is the same
story with deep learning or anything
basically they find your what you're
looking for maybe they find a few things
you're looking for then it's the end
or if it doesn't work out well they
don't but either way it's the end
natural evolution is still diverging and
doing something interesting
interesting is the key word right
because divergence just for the sake of
divergence that could be the worst thing
in the world we don't want to be
doing completely random things that
aren't interesting so what does
interesting mean
well interestingness simply means that
you're accumulating information
right the amount of information that you
have is
growing and what does that information
mean or do well it could be anything it
could be helping
the agents in your world exploit the
environment better
novelty is kind of a proxy for it
novelty is not equivalent to
interestingness interesting this is
richer
and also harder to formalize but novelty
is
kind of close to what interestingness is
and so the idea is
what if you only followed gradients of
novelty
and novelty is just really fascinating
as a gradient you know because it's
actually very well informed
because it's basically a comparison of
where you are to where you were in the
past
and so it's actually just really the
opposite of an objective because an
objective is comparing where you are to
where you want to be in the future
but neither has more information like
people have this intuition when they
hear about this the novelty search is
kind of random
but objective search is like not random
because you're comparing to the
objective
but that couldn't be further from the
case i mean there's actually more
information about the past than the
future because actually was there so i
know what i actually
had so i can compute novelty with
respect to some record of where i've
been in the past
and have a very defined gradient but the
really interesting thing about
information accumulation as opposed to
any other objectives
is that there is one direction right it
does monotonically increase
information accumulation is the only
objective which does increase
monotonically
but we shouldn't think of it as an
objective the whole point of stanley's
conception
is that there is no one objective it's
more like meta-learning
where there are an infinite sea of
objectives which are learned through
some kind of
search process right and the fascinating
thing about these systems is that when
you have
the diffuse diversity of objectives
then in a sense there is no
objectiveness to the system at all
because it becomes completely fluid
and for that reason it can accumulate
information and it can diverge
continuously
what it illustrates when you sometimes
win with novelty is just
how profoundly weak objectives are in
terms of like really being a good
guiding light
you know they're just so much less than
you think they are it's an absolute
embarrassment for
objectives that something that doesn't
even know what problem it's trying to
solve
is doing better at solving the problem
than the objectively driven version of
the same exact algorithm
the other fascinating thing that we
explore in the show today is that our
existence is not entirely explained
by selection so we've been thinking
about this entirely the wrong way
it's actually the operating search
structure which is exploited by
evolution
that's what makes it so interesting if
you really think you understand
something
from an ai perspective then you should
be able to formalize it and write it
down
and then it should give me what i'm
asking for so if that's all evolution is
then let's just write it down and then
we'll have open-endedness and you've
just revolutionized the field
and which is why i think it probably is
not just that it's probably not just
anything that anybody here thinks it
just is
you may have read your biology textbooks
and you may think that you know what
evolution is and it may make sense
but actually i can almost assure you
that there's going to be a few
counter-intuitive kind of curveballs
that are thrown into that story
that we learned in high school which
aren't in the textbook because if there
weren't we would just take the textbook
and formalize it and it's not that
simple and people been trying to do this
for 50 60 years so evolution is a very
complicated and subtle process
and what we mean by it is different than
just optimization if we're talking about
the open-endedness aspect of it which is
probably the more interesting aspect of
it
if you're just saying from an
optimization you know perspective like
how can i explain why
hyenas are as fast as they are okay
there maybe you can give me an
explanation
but that's not the same as sort of
formalizing the whole thing as a process
that's going to produce this kind of
grandiosity of nature on earth
open-ended search is definitely a cool
research direction and i encourage you
to check it out
all of these different challenges that
you're seeing here were invented by the
algorithm as it's running
and also the agent that is solving that
problem was also
invented at the same time and over time
these environments get more and more
complicated
we did the counterfactual we went back
to the 298 agent and we just ran it
forever we gave it tons and tons of
computation
and it was stuck on a local optima it
never stood up the
if you just let that thing run forever
it only gets a score of 309 and it keeps
that knee on the ground for whatever
reason because the landscape is
deceptive
so counter-intuitively in this
particular problem you had to go from a
simple problem
to a harder problem and then come back
to the simple problem in order to get
the right solution to the simple problem
which is just a curriculum that a human
would never design but these algorithms
figure out
on their own which is the beauty of
these things just dropping an agent in
that
environment and trying to solve it
because there's no curricula to get
there or by taking kind of like what you
would
see is the direct path here are some
solutions that traditional optimization
cannot solve but poet does find a
solution to some of these really really
crazy
environments any of these really
challenging problems when you're going
to go back and look at it
you cannot directly optimize to solve
that problem so
very quickly poet is kind of quality
diversity plus plus
because as ken said it breaks the mold
it now can generate its own niches in
addition to trying to have all the other
properties
is it truly open-ended well no it's not
because
well it's definitely a step closer
because it's generating its own niches
it's currently limited by the fact that
we picked a specific physics simulator
and a specific way to parameterize
environments in that physics simulator
the stepping stones that lead to where
you may want to go are only accessible
to you if you open your mind and are
willing to actually accept things that
don't look better objectively
so i like to give the example walking
like on the road to learning to walk you
have to learn about oscillation
but if you just start oscillating your
legs while you're standing or something
like that you'll just fall on your face
but if i look at it from like is that
interesting it's very interesting it's a
completely new
idea i've never seen that before so in
the novelty version of the world i would
be like okay let's go down that path i
don't know where this leads but it's
something i haven't seen before
but in the objective version i'm like
nope try something else so what will i
try like i'll try like lunging as far as
i can or something that's
in the short term like looks like i'm
actually making progress but in the long
run it's going nowhere because you're
not going to be able to walk based on
just like throwing your body forward as
fast as you can
but the larger lesson is just like let's
take seriously other gradients like the
gradient of novelty
so this serves as an interesting lesson
for gophi
advocates good old-fashioned ai there
are many good old-fashioned ai folks
challenging machine learning and the
statistical approaches to ai
saying that knowledge is universal and
should be explicitly constructed
but what about knowledge which is not
yet in our possession
kenneth and joel's poet paper
demonstrates explicitly
that there's plenty of knowledge about
existing earthly systems
which we don't fully understand we
understand the what
but not the how the how will only become
known
possibly through some open-ended
discovery process
because the stepping stones to that
final knowledge you know the how
will not in any way resemble the current
what that we have in our minds so in a
sense
knowledge engineering is only possible
if you understood it in the first place
if we understood how to build a compiler
for language
then natural language understanding
would be solved
we don't understand it that's the whole
problem right
it's the same thing convolutional neural
networks they started dominating the
computer vision world after 2012 and
it was precisely because the
representations learned as part of the
training process were better than any
handcrafted features
it just it was a complete game changer
and even now we don't fully understand
how they work we have to
resort to all sorts of esoteric methods
to do interpretability on on these
models but
that's just the way it is but have you
noticed now that gophi people they
recognize neural networks as being part
of the
architecture for any agi system they use
the term
perception right so so perception means
a module which
cannot be explicitly crafted with
knowledge because it's not
understandable yet by humans even
bayesian aficionados they point out
the lack of causal inferencing in these
neural network models they just say look
they are
statistical correlation machines that
there's no causal factors
and yeah in a sense they're true but i'm
not really sure their alternative is
better
what they are proposing is that you
impute the causal factors
into the model architecture explicitly
right so you already know what the
causal factors are
you know that male testosterone causes
car accidents so you
you build a probabilistic graphical
model that has that causal factor in
well
yeah that's great if you know what the
causal factor is right
what about all of the causal factors out
there that we don't know
you know bayesian approaches are not
going to help you then are they
what we need to have is is a new way of
discovering that knowledge
and potentially kenneth stanley's
approach might be leading us in that
direction right because
stanley instead explores the seemingly
infinite space of knowledge which is not
yet known
um you know interestingly he focuses on
information accumulation as being one of
the core kind of tenants of of of his
paradigm
and in recent years also discovering new
problems
and new solutions in tandem rather than
you know solutions to one specific task
okay so
an amazing blog dropped this morning by
this guy mark
sarafin actually we're getting him on
the podcast at the end of february so
you can look forward to that but
he just wrote this wonderful article
called machine learning
the great stagnation right and i'm not
going to spoil the surprise too much
because of course we'll be talking to
mark but
he he leads by saying academics think of
themselves
as trailblazers explorers seekers of the
truth
any fundamental discovery involves a
significant degree
of risk if an idea is guaranteed to work
then it moves from the realm of research
to engineering
unfortunately this also means that most
research careers will
invariably be failures at least if
failures are measured by
objective metrics like citations
so the construction of academia was
predicted on providing a downside hedge
or safety net for researchers
where they can pursue ambitious ideas so
mark points out that
academics sacrifice material opportunity
costs in exchange for intellectual
freedom
society admires risk takers for its only
you know their heroic self-sacrifice
that society moves forward
he points out that most of the
admiration and prestige that we have
towards academics are from a bygone time
uh economists were the first to figure
out how to maintain the prestige of
academia while
not taking any monetary or intellectual
risk they'd show up on
cnbc finance talking about corrections
or irrational fear and exuberance
so mark says that it's hard to point the
blame towards any individual researcher
after all while risk is good for the
collective it's almost
necessarily bad for the individual
however this risk-free approach is
growing in popularity and has
specifically permeated machine learning
right the the fang's salary with an
academic appointment is the best job
available in the world today
and with all of the sota chasing we're
rewarding and lording
incremental research as innovators
increasing their budget so that they can
do even more
incremental research parallelized over
as many employees or graduate students
that report to them
what exactly are you doing yeah yeah
i've just been really busy chasing sota
so he's fundamentally saying that you
know machine learning researchers now
can engage in risk-free high-income high
prestige work
and they are today's medieval catholic
priests
this is an absolutely hilarious article
i mean i'm not going to spoil all of it
for you but
i'll do a bit more so machine learning
phd students are a new
kind of investment banking analyst in in
mark's opinion
both seek optionality in their career
choices but different superficial ways
like
preferring meditation over parties and
marijuana and adderall
over alcohol and cocaine you know so he
points out that
a machine learning phd is now kind of
like an extended interview for the tech
industry whether it's facebook or
microsoft
and google the entire data science
interview process at the larger labs has
now just become a mix of trivia and
prestige
you know checking out your portfolio
would take far too long it's far easier
just to say well
you know have you graduated from
stanford or do you have a paper
co-authored with google brain
that's a good filter so yeah he says
that you know matrix multiplication is
all you need
he's got some absolutely hilarious memes
here
so you're telling me it's all matrix
multiplications
always has mean yeah some of these
things are brilliant rise are the
transformers attention is all you need
transformer on proteins transformers on
molecules transformers on images fast
transformer
transformers are graph neural networks
learning to transform with transformers
oh this is hilarious as well so he's got
this concept called graduate student
descent and the death of first
principles
this chart below describes how graduate
student descent works so essentially you
you uh initialize you find the sotter on
archive
you find the code on github if worse you
make random changes and then you publish
so this is uh
it's a bit of a piss take but to be
honest it's not too far from the truth
statistical learning gentlemen our
learner over generalizes because of the
vc the vapnik chervanescus the dimension
of our kernel is too high
get some experts and minimize the
structural risk in a new one
rework our loss function make the next
kernel stable unbiased
and consider using a soft margin
language models in particular like gbt3
are starting to feel a lot like the
large hadron collider
but no language has ontologies which
you're not capturing with
self-supervised learning your approach
isn't research because it's not sample
efficient like humans
you can't even interpret the weights and
the other was like
as you go hilariously he points out that
bert engineer is now a full-time job
qualifications include
and i'm guilty of this by the way sun
bash scripting
check deep knowledge of pip waiting for
a new hugging face model to be released
jack watching yannick kilcher's new
transformer paper the day it comes out
guilty as charge uh repeating what janik
said at your team
reading group guilty as charged it's
kind of like
devops i'm all over that by the way but
you get paid more
yeah so i mean you know obviously we've
got to be able to take the piss out of
ourselves a little bit
in the machine learning community that
you know you you could say that this is
just posting
but um it you know there's there's
obviously a large kernel of truth to
what mark is saying
yeah um so imparting at the end he says
that he's sad to see that the most
exciting work in machine learning
is coming from outside of machine
learning he says he spent 10 years in
this field and he learns more from
the crackpot outsiders on twitter today
than he does from peer-reviewed papers
and i think that
that says quite a lot really anyway
we're talking with mark
at the end of february so i hope you
look forward to that it's quite an
interesting piece here as well
about the bio and tech vaccine which was
uh um
recently approved and this lady catalin
carrico she pioneered this work into
mrna
therapeutics and vaccines going back
many decades but
the problem was that this article tells
a really fascinating story about when
she was at her lowest ebb
she was a biochemist at the university
of pennsylvania
and she dedicated like the previous two
decades of finding a way to turn
one of the most fundamental building
blocks of life mrna into a whole new
category of therapeutics and she found
herself hitting lots of dead ends
to cut a long story short there was a
problem with using mrna because the
there was an immune response from humans
and that needed to be attenuated
so um her bosses just ran out of
patience she got demoted and she
basically got told that you know she
couldn't work on this anymore
and this is a wonderful example of group
thinking objectives in a way because
we can't trust innovation centers or
universities or companies to innovate
because to innovate you have to
basically explore
into the unknown and this was a
wonderful example of
you know luckily this woman had the
initiative
and the persistence and the perseverance
to
continue with her dream she really
believed deep down
that she could make this work and she
placed herself at considerable personal
hardship and risk to make it happen and
then
because of this incredible work from
this woman
we now have another vaccine for
coronavirus which we wouldn't have had
otherwise so
it goes to show that we really need
folks out there like
catalin who pursue their passions and
interests
and innovate for the benefit of all of
us so pick breeder was
influential in the genesis a lot of the
ideas that we've been discussing today
is for the audience like where does all
this come from
this was like a website where you can
just breed pictures
but the the kind of clever twist of that
was that
if you brought a picture basically you
would be evolving the pictures like you
choose a picture and it would have
babies and then you could
choose the ones that you like and they
would have children and so forth and
then you could like publish your picture
on our website that you found
by evolving it but this clever twist is
that you could then
someone else could come in see your
picture and then branch and start
evolving from there
so we had people evolving from where
other people left off
and so it was kind of experimenting at
some level
so it's sort of like it's like what you
might think of if you're breeding
horses or dogs or something like that
but in this case it's just pictures
and so you could go online and see some
blobs and you could choose the blob you
like and it would have children that
look kind of like it but are a little
bit different
just like if you're breeding a horse or
a dog or something like that but the key
thing that makes it sort of special
is that and sometimes this is called
genetic art by the way some people may
have heard of that or evolutionary art
but the thing that made pick readers
special is that it was a website so
if you did discover something or breed
something that was cool you could
publish it
press a button that says publish and
would go back to the site and then
somebody else could come in and then
breed from there
so they start out with very simple
pattern and you just have the
opportunity to kind of
you pick one and it gives you a bunch of
random perturbations of the procedurally
generated image and
you pick the ones that you like and then
you continue exploring from there
and if you're happy you can just save
that to the database and someone else
can look through the database and then
pick
yours for example to continue so people
were building on things that people
built on that people built on that
people built on it's basically standing
on the shoulders of your predecessors
and you end up getting this giant
branching phylogeny of
pictures and it was ultimately for me
and i don't know it's up it's obviously
subjective it was ultimately for me
astonishing what people discovered
like these were generated by little tiny
neural networks and we had skulls and
butterflies and cars and stuff like that
and so it turned out that yeah the the
notion of what's interesting
which every person uh has a different
notion was
was instrumental in allowing that
process to happen
in in what i think is a completely
phenomenal process of discovery because
like the number of iterations involved
in say finding something like the skull
was in the dozens like think about that
compared to deep learning
thousands or millions or billions of
iterations this is like
dozens of iterations to find things that
are absolutely
extremely rare needles in a haystack
what is the explanation for that indeed
part of it is that we have a very very
strong nose for the interesting as human
beings
and that it's diverse we're not all
looking for the same stuff
and the things that the humans came up
with or that the result of that was
extremely interesting now something like
pick breeder is much more kind of like
close to like actually following
gradients of interestingness
because it's human beings that are
making the decision and humans arguably
make decisions on what's interesting
what is it that makes systems like pick
breeder work
so effectively open-ended systems in
general
and what it is is basically it's the
connection between one stepping stone
and the next
you're just doing things that are random
like people in pickport are not doing
things that are random
it's not like just clicking randomly on
images just hoping something good
happens they're obviously doing things
for some reason why are they doing them
it's like if i click on this and then it
leads to like some pattern like that's
symmetric or something and i like it
it's not because i'm like oh well now
i'm gonna get a butterfly
it's because the pattern in its own
right is just interesting to me
and this is not like a random fact this
is based on like the the full force of
all of my intelligence is still being
put on to making this decision that i
like this pattern
so it's hardly a trivial gradient that
i'm following that connection like if
there's a very very
salient stepping stone for you just for
you this could change your life
like if you look at this picture of this
butterfly or something like this
it will not be true if the majority of
people and so
we will never get to follow down that
path if it's a majority rules type of
voting situation
we need you to be able to follow your
special special instinct
because that was the thing that could
change only your life the system
is designed basically to try to raise
things up that people find interesting
the images that were discovered by pick
breeder users were discovered by people
who were not trying to discover them
and that is because of deception i have
to make a strong argument
that pick reader actually is like real
life and and i do think it is
and the reason that i think it is is
because pick reader is actually much
much simpler than real life
like in pick reader if you take any
arbitrary image like the skull
and you say okay well how would i get
there from scratch like
we don't really know how to get there
from scratch that metric of improvement
of like how close are we to a skull is
not the right one
for following that trajectory through
the search space that's basically the
definition of a hard problem
like if you knew what the stepping
stones were it wouldn't be hard we would
just follow the stepping stones of
course
sometimes you have to be following the
other by other i mean not the objective
gradient not the thing that leads to
where you're hoping to go
but something that leads somewhere along
a different line but which has value
anyway
in every case where something really
cool was discovered like say a car
or a butterfly or something like that
there is some predecessor image in other
words an
ancestor where the person who discovered
that ancestor was not trying to get the
thing that was ultimately discovered
and this is like 99.99 of cases it is an
experiment an evolutionary computation
but it's also an experiment like mass
level collaboration
like huge massive collaboration but
where there's no explicit collaboration
so nobody's talking to somebody else
like how am i going to work with you
like who should i work with
it's just here's this artifact i
discovered hand it off to the world and
then someone else might take that baton
and then move it forward again
and we got really really large branching
phylogenies is what you would call it
like trees of evolution because people
would branch off of people off of people
and we could actually show it as a graph
like these huge phylogenys
of pictures basically and just amazing
pictures were discovered
um you know things that you wouldn't
think that from just random blobs you
could evolve things like cars and
butterflies and skulls and all kinds of
very recognizable objects were involved
and certainly it's some kind of a
democratization you know it's like
humans in the loop so it's
it's kind of different from nero and
since it's like a mass many people
experiment but
it has this extra element which is that
like
there is a lot of potential for the
combination
of learning in humans um where
we still are better at certain things
than a.i and
this is what we call divergence in other
words
the system rather than converging to the
uber image whatever that might mean
is actually diverging across the space
of all that's possible
and collecting stepping stones extremely
valuable as an example of
how an open-ended process can develop
because we know every single choice that
was made
you can only get to these things by not
trying so pick breeder was
a website that was launched a very long
time ago now and
i can't really demonstrate it properly
because it's not working
uh without java applets and i don't
think anyone uses java applets anymore
so you can see the parents and the
children so you could
this particular one had this parent and
then that parent
and then that parent and the fascinating
thing with pick breeder is that quite
often the parents
do not even resemble the children
although in this case it kind of does
quite interesting so when we go up the
tree high enough we see that the parents
were just
basically blank images so there was a
rating system on there you could see
which the best images uh
were rated so there are foxes and ghosts
and
a lot of um kind of anthropomorphic
images as well which shouldn't surprise
you given that humans are
you know essentially supervising the
process you can see the highest rated
images here some of them are fascinating
that looks a bit like a monkey
that looks a bit like a baby's face some
fruit
how are these things generated well it's
it's easier than you think actually
so this was the original java
application that people used to use for
pick breeder
essentially it's a human augmented
distributed evolution algorithm
and the population included individuals
which were compositional pattern
producing networks or cppns
now it's not as complicated as it sounds
they're right here actually so a cppn
is a neural network that takes in a
spatial input and has an output in three
color channels so we have an rgb
now there are four inputs here i can't
remember exactly what the four inputs
are but basically think of it as an x
and a y maybe there's a bias in there or
something
but um what happens is the user clicks
on the result so so this is the
underlying pattern producing network and
then there'll be
a result which is shown so for example
those ones i just
showed you there they all produce
slightly different results and they
produce different results because
they're variations of each other they
have a slightly different
topology or they might have different
weights or activation functions
the activation functions that are used
are are just an optional set as well so
you can just
check all of those off so the only thing
we're missing here really is
how do we make that evolution algorithm
produce mutations and crossovers in the
neural network space because we're
actually searching through the space of
neural network topologies if you think
about it and
that is using something called neat okay
so a very long time ago now
kenneth stanley pioneered this algorithm
called
neat which is evolving neural networks
through augmenting topologies
and basically it was an evolutionary
algorithm for neural networks a
population-based
method and what do you need to do to
implement an evolutionary algorithm
where you need to know how to
represent neural networks and cross them
over and mutate them
and there was also a challenge as well
because as you'll remember from our
conversation with max welling
you have these symmetries especially on
topology right so you can have two
graphs which are basically the same
thing they are
symmetry transformations of each other
but the problem is when you when you
cross over those two networks they can
kind of cancel each other out
and this is what kenneth stanley called
the competing conventions problem
so we need to have a system that can
solve that okay so
the core concept with neat is how do you
represent neural networks in such a way
that you can
mutate them later so we have the concept
of a genome and this basically just
you know is a list of all of the things
that's ever happened to a particular
neural network
so you can see the nodes and you can see
the connections
and what's interesting about this neural
network is that um
number five came along later so
originally two is connected to four
so you can see here that number five got
added and it's just like a stack you
just add all of the innovations on
forever
it's a bit like a transaction log in a
database or something like that you know
you you kind of keep a record of
everything that happened before
so number five came along and you can
actually see here that we've got all of
the innovation numbers and monotonically
increasing sequence
and the interesting thing is that one of
them has been disabled
well i wonder why that is well this
particular one is going from two to four
so from there to there and it needed to
be disabled because now five is in
is in the way so five came along and
then you can see here
the sequence of things that happened so
now we've got one going from two to five
which is there so that was added and of
course this was disabled straight away
and then we've got from five to four
right and then the last one is from
four to five and then one to five so
presumably five got added
this connection got added the original
connection between two to four was
deleted
and then we had two new connections
between two to five and four to five
so how do we do mutations well let's
have a look so if we wanted to add a
connection to this network let's say
from five to three
all we do is we add a new innovation
number on the end so innovation seven
and we just say three to five okay easy
what if we wanted to do something a
little bit more complicated so we wanted
to add in
a new node here six so this is a
a node that didn't exist before well in
order to do that we'd have to disable
the original connection right from three
to four
because now we've got six in the way so
this one's a little bit more complicated
so here we put
an innovation eight in going from three
to six and then nine going from six to
four
and we delete the old innovation from
three to four so yeah and this is a
population-based method so of course we
have many many different
types of topology going on but they will
all be sharing
the same kind of genome if you like but
of course
they'll be specialized in the sense that
some of them will have
additions in terms of innovations or
some of them will have previous
innovations disabled
so you can you can imagine how we can
make an algorithm to do this
automatically because it's basically
just
a random mutation so you just need to
essentially come up with a place to
put your new node which activation
function do you want which weight do you
want and so on so that's reasonably
straightforward
the next thing of course is in the world
of pick breeder
it's a human augmented process so so the
humans basically pick the children
and then the crossover is performed so
how do you do the crossover
well the beauty of having this
innovation system is you just kind of
like line up all of the innovations
and if there are any disabled so it's
like an
or on the disabled then the child is
disabled so here for example
um if we cross over these two parents
because one of these is disabled then
the
the child must be disabled as well um if
there are any gaps then it just gets
filled in
and that's basically how you produce the
offspring so this offspring
gets the eight from parent one um
everything else
um comes from parent two and then if
there are any disabled nodes then
the offspring is disabled and then it
produces this child topology
so it's actually surprisingly simple and
this is the you know
the foundation of how pick breeder works
but yeah this neat algorithm is
absolutely fascinating because
probably most of you are reinforcement
learning aficionados and
uh you haven't really thought about
using any other approaches for let's say
building policies for controlling agents
and i think this is a fairly cool
example on github i found where
someone had used neet to learn a policy
to control the game of snake
and this was the topology which was
found you know through this
population search and um it works
incredibly well you know you don't
necessarily have to use reinforcement
learning
which should be uh interesting for some
of you to hear so how do i apply these
ideas in my life
well there's a trade-off isn't there
between things that you know will pay
off
investments of your time versus
investing in things or creating a
fertile ground for discoveries so
there's an interesting dichotomy between
the manufacture and discovery of
opportunities
in our lives i got a message on steam
the other day from someone who wanted to
play counter-strike with me now
i've known this person for years
presumably he plays counter-strike 20
or so hours a day um do i want to play
counter-strike
no it's not interesting to me i i just i
have a sense
that it's not going to lead anywhere
interesting i mean of course we don't
really know where things lead but
we have an innate sense for
interestingness and it's different for
all of us
perhaps if i wanted to get a career in
esports or something like that
then i would find that investment would
pay off for me but
i invest in other things you might ask
yourself why
am i running this youtube channel i
don't monetize it i don't get any money
from it i don't get anything from it
well that's not true at all right first
of all it's
incredibly serendipitous that i met
yannick
it was icml 2019 i was there and yannick
was there we were both staying in the
same hotel but we didn't meet each other
then
in fact i didn't even go to the tutorial
on open-endedness and he did
he made a video about it connor shorten
then reached out to yannick because of
that video
and then i um happened on connor
shorten's videos and
he introduced me to yannick and we
decided to make this youtube channel
together that was pure luck it was
serendipity
and i do this youtube channel because
yeah it leads to so many interesting
opportunities later i could build an
audience of people that trust me
maybe i could monetize it later maybe it
will lead to career opportunities
it's a forcing function for me to get
really good at all the latest and
greatest in ai
it means that i can facilitate lots of
conversations with people that i
wouldn't otherwise have been able to do
it's just it's an incredible um
all-round fertile
kind of cultivation process for
opportunities
so this is open-endedness and manifested
in in my life
i have a strong intuition that it will
lead to something very interesting later
whether i'm learning more about machine
learning and artificial intelligence
i'm learning about creative pursuits
whether it's making 3d renders or video
editing or
graphic design my communication skills
my written skills
if you want to have an all-round kind of
skill acceleration process i thoroughly
recommend you all to start your own
youtube channel because within
a couple of years any weak links are
accentuated greatly it's very easy to do
an audio podcast it's very easy to do a
blog
try doing a youtube channel it's an
order of magnitude more difficult one of
the key messages that kenneth is talking
about is that we should all be treasure
hunters
we should identify some domains of
what's interesting to us
and we should create a fertile
environment to
maximize the number of opportunities we
have because it's a numbers game at the
end of the day
opportunities do come and arise and we
should have the same idea in science and
in engineering and
just in what we do at work we should be
building platforms and building systems
that create and manufacture
opportunities and cross-pollination
so by being a treasure hunter it means
that all the things that we
hoped might happen in the future will
become more likely
because you know the more stepping
stones we have the more places that we
can get to the stepping stones you end
up on
might not be where you had planned to go
but kenneth would argue you shouldn't be
planning anyway
anyway i really hope you've enjoyed the
show today and and will enjoy the
interview with kenneth it's been
so much fun making it uh this this has
been
i've been planning to make this
particular show for what seems like an
eternity now
and there have been so many events that
have conspired against me so i'm so glad
to finally get this out there
remember to like comment and subscribe
we love reading your comments and we'll
see you back
next week i gotta say i'm kind of i'm
both disappointed and intrigued that
you're
no longer at ucf i was so looking
forward to visiting you down on campus
one day when i visit family in florida
but now you're at this cool place so
it's an
equally cool place welcome back
to the machine learning street talk
youtube channel and podcast
with me tim scarf and my two compadres
mit phd
dr keith duggar yannick lightspeed
culture
and today we have an incredibly special
guest professor kenneth stanley
now i've been dreaming about getting
kenneth on the show since the very
beginning some of you might recall that
our first ever show
was on the enhanced poet paper you know
the uh pairwise open ended trailblazer
and of course kenneth had his hands
all over that uh kenneth held a charles
milliken professorship
and was a field professor at the
university of central florida
he's an associate editor at the
frontiers in robotics and ai
and also the ieee transactions on
computational intelligence
and ai in games he's on the advisory
board for the o'reilly artificial
intelligence conference
and the spring natural computing book
series he's been cited
over 16 000 times his most popular paper
with over 3000 citations
was the neat algorithm which is evolving
neural networks through augmenting
topologies
and that's a genetic algorithm for the
generation of evolving artificial neural
networks
he's currently a research science
manager at open ai in san francisco
he was a senior research manager at uber
for three and a half years
he completed his phd in computer science
from the university of texas
in austin his interests are in
neuroevolution
open-endedness neural networks
artificial life
and artificial intelligence he invented
the concept of novelty search
with no clearly defined objective his
idea is that there's a tyranny of
objectives prevailing in every aspect of
our lives
society and indeed our algorithms
crucially these objectives produce
convergent behavior
and thinking and distract us from
discovering stepping stones
which might lead to greatness he thinks
that this monotonic objective obsession
this idea that we need to continue to
improve benchmarks every single year
is dangerous sarah hooker recently spoke
about the hardware lottery
how the previous software and hardware
decisions enslave us
but in my opinion the objective lottery
is so much worse
he wrote about this in detail in his
recent book greatness can't be planned
which is the main topic of discussion in
the show this evening
he introduces several very important
concepts the false compass or deception
treasure hunting we should all be
treasure hunters my friends
this book has really touched me in
particular modifying many of the key
uh you know aspects of my personal
philosophy in life so i'm very indebted
to kenya for writing that book
kenneth stanley welcome to the show
thank you tim uh it is it is an honor to
be here i'm really happy to be on this
show i've enjoyed this show i watched
this show before and uh really happy to
actually be here finally
myself so thanks amazing
you have a very interesting philosophy
which is quite contrarian actually
because
as you said objectives seem to dominate
our lives and and society
and from the very beginning you've been
pushing against that that grain if you
like so
where did it come from well before
before he answers that is
is it a fair assessment that tim just
gave because for example when i read the
you know the abandoning objectives white
paper
it's not remotely as extreme as like a
tyranny of objectives etc etc
dominating our life you know it's much
more nuanced like it says hey look
maybe the best approach is to take you
know the some of the
uh things we find in novelty search and
then apply objective based
optimization to them and if we kind of
look at the history of humanity
it has been this dual-sided coin you
know i mean out-of-the-box thinking is
nothing new
serendipity is nothing new exploration's
always been a big part of human
endeavors
and yet we can even the scientific
method right begins the first step is
observe hypothesize right test
repeat so i mean we've always had this
dual sided coin of explorer
combined with optimizing those results
how many great scientists formulated
their hypothesis before they're
discovering
i'd say all of them observed before they
hypothesized
and observation is exploration
okay interesting i i so i i guess so
this is i think the question that tim is
asking is
is more i'm interpreting more as a
personal question like how i came to
these views
and keith is is is rightly pointing out
that we can't simply dismiss all
objectives in in the world i mean
obviously there's
no there is an important role for
objective pursuits in the world
but nevertheless i think it's true that
like even though i recognize that so i'm
not on this
exact extremum of the spectrum i mean
that's just not where i am
even though i and i recognize that i
think it's it's true that i'm just
tend to be more of a radical on this
particular axis
it is in my personality in nature to
want
to overthrow this i guess we could say
tyranny of objectives
even though i do recognize that
certainly sometimes they
they they have merit and and have to be
used and followed
but it's true that sort of like
throughout my life i i just seem to be
have have an intuitive tendency to want
to reject
objective driven type of endeavors
and go in the opposite direction and so
it probably started out as a personality
issue maybe it's a maybe it's a
personality problem
but so maybe some a degree of
rebelliousness although it doesn't
exhibit in all aspects of my life but
there's some degree of rebelliousness
but i think that it crystallized over
time
especially at that moment when we
started discovering this principle
like if it the the moment sort of where
we saw this principle in pick reader was
probably transformative for me
because before that it would have been
really implicit maybe in my personality
that i just kind of
didn't like being told what to do maybe
you could say i sort of felt
intuitively that like sometimes i don't
understand why i have to justify where
i'm going
when it's clearly very interesting uh in
some objective manner
but when we started discovering this
principle in a more formal sense in pick
breeder
you know it's like the the discovery
somehow like intersected with my
personality
and then really launched me to the point
where i might use the word tyranny or
though i don't think we really went as
far as calling it tyranny
but but yeah it's it that then that
really triggered
eventually you know the impetus to write
a whole book about this
because i felt that it's not a topic of
discussion right now in in our culture
and i wanted to start that discussion at
least or try
to start that discussion because this
isn't you're not seeing demonstrations
on the street about this
like you know getting rid of objectives
this is this is a very very entrenched
status quo
it's not even controversial it's that
objectives basically
rule our culture in our society and so i
guess it aligns with my personality but
i started to feel that there's a
preponderance of scientific evidence to
go along with it
and this leads to i would also say like
just because you're asking me sort of
about why like why did this happen i
just want to point out that
it wasn't you're right keith that the
the original paper didn't have that kind
of radical bent to it
like the white paper on abandoning
objectives and it wasn't i didn't start
feeling this kind of radical view until
i was talking about this
for for years like i kind of got on a
almost on tour
because because there was such a
counter-intuitive point like you should
abandon your objectives in order to
achieve them
like the discussions that i was getting
at computer science conferences
after giving talks about this became
more and more personal
until i started getting invited to
places that weren't computer science
conferences like one of the first one
was the rhode island school of design
where i spoke to a whole group of
artists and that was a really for me
transformative experience because they
were
it was like a cathartic therapeutic
session i didn't expect that
but all these artists were thanking me
and saying finally like we understand
why we're doing what we're doing we
haven't been able to justify to our
parents
to our teachers we haven't been able to
explain why are we doing these things
that seem
you know pointless maybe you could say
and i started to realize that like this
is a way bigger issue
than just like an algorithmic concept
that we have to
think about in terms of you know should
we balance objectives with some other
kind of diversification and algorithms
but this is actually something that's
pervading our lives and actually
inhibiting a lot of people from reaching
their potential
and so i was like i gradually came to
the more radical view
and wanted to express it that way after
speaking a lot with a lot of people
and realizing that it's becoming
personal was a really strange thing i
mean it was
for me it was entirely an algorithmic
point that we were making it's very
very dry and very scientific and it just
sort of
dawned on me over time that this is not
just about science this is about our
institutions in our personal lives and
so i
came to this point through a
transformation that happened over years
and and that's why i'm now you know and
sitting here
acting like a radical about this it's
not like i just immediately started out
that way
at what point does the the science no
longer support your radicalism
because we we kind of have another
pervasive problem in society today which
is that
people take science and extend it far
beyond like what the science actually
tells us it's kind of like oh if science
hints that you know
five percent of the time we have a
certain problem some agenda-driven
people out there are gonna say it's
actually 95 percent of the the problem
that we have so
do you run the risk of kind of getting
off the firm
you know foundation that you had saying
the white paper and moving kind of
into areas where in fact you don't have
evidence to support that radical view
it is a risk but we'd have to we'd have
to really analyze
you know whether this is this is
actually happening like in the arguments
that we're making
i mean clearly it's you know before you
read the book it's a risk
i i think if you read the book maybe not
you because i think if you when you read
the book you didn't feel that
we got around that risk but but
hopefully someone who read the book
would see that we were measured
in our approach and actually tried to be
realistic about this like in that we're
not
you know in the first chapter we're
saying okay let's let's concede
that in many many cases objectives are
effective
and we should use them and this is
really about blue sky types of discovery
and innovation
which is an important aspect of our
culture i mean we we thrive on that in
this in in western culture and
and also in other cultures as well and
so it's very important that we run those
kinds of things carefully
and people's lives are also affected by
that and i think
so we try to to circumscribe where we're
making this argument clearly and maybe
that that failed in your case
but i think that i think that it is
actually realistically applied in this
in our case but we could argue about the
details there
so i think that if it's extreme like
the one of this 5 to 95 kind of like you
know just
wishy-washy kind of talk new age kind of
talk
you could you could go in that direction
but one of the reasons that we wrote the
book
was because we have all this empirical
evidence
you know this is not like a new age feel
good self-help book
they don't start out with like a bunch
of scientific experiments with empirical
evidence
it's true though that like the extension
of the empirical evidence into
normal life we could argue about i guess
we probably will
but i but i think that those extensions
are reasonable
and what's happening here is just that
the status quo is resistant
to a challenge because it's not used to
it this is not the kind of thing most
people challenge
like just that hey uh if you're going to
do something measure progress towards it
that's just like obvious to 99
to people out there and so to say to
strenuously
argue that like that actually is not a
good idea
that's tough to swallow i think so i
think what's actually happening is just
the status quo is naturally resisting
the fact that it turns out not to be the
correct approach
in many many cases when we're striving
towards this kind of blue sky innovation
and that's tough to swallow it's it's
interesting
the there is a there's a subtle
distinction that you
you make sometimes and one hand you say
something like
sometimes we should drop our objectives
in order to reach them
right so sometimes we should let go of
them in order to reach them and there
are
you know certain discoveries we want to
reach the moon we should drop the
objective of building a better plane or
something like this but then in in other
cases
for example in pick breeder there is no
objective right so you drop the
objective but
what you reach isn't necessarily what
you want it to reach
right do you see like uh is is this for
you two different paths
could i just have a quick go at that
because the the moon one is an
interesting example
i think kenneth would argue that all of
the intermediate stepping stones for
landing on the moon
might not resemble the end goal
pick breeder we will introduce that in
in a little while but
that's a little bit different that that
is a kind of human augmented
evolution process where at every stage
of the evolution
cycle humans can select things that that
they
like the look of well rocketry is an
interesting one because in fact the
intermediate steps looked exactly like
the
the end product of the saturn v you know
i mean you can trace a very clear
evolution all the way back to like
chinese you know sort of rocket
fireworks and see how that was an
optimization effort like to build that
rocket that got to the moon
so what i'm what i'm getting at sort of
is that
if if you if you run something like pick
breeder
don't you run the danger of sure you'll
reach something
but is that thing that you'll reach any
any useful
yeah yeah yeah yeah i get it and
actually there's
there's two parallel threads in this in
what we just discussed so that makes it
that makes a little tricky to answer
because there's this this one question
that yannick is asking about like the
difference between
becoming less objective in service of
getting to in effect an objective
versus just being less objective with
the knowledge that we don't even know
where we're going but it might be
somewhere interesting
that's one interesting dichotomy and
then there's this other issue of like
okay if if we did do something really
really impressive like get to the moon
which we did we could argue about
whether we were being objective or not
objective like that's another issue
actually and and i agree actually
with what tim was was saying about that
latter issue
that i think a strong argument could be
made that the stepping stones that lead
there
largely do not resemble there of course
though that's going to be an argument
because it already was we just started
arguing about it but i think that's a
little bit orthogonal to what yannick
was pointing out
so i'll try to get i'll try to first
address that which is basically
yes that it is true that the the
the ultimate principle that that the
book is advocating
does lead you to a point where you don't
know where you're going
and therefore it's not designed to
produce a particular
outcome that you had in mind before you
went off on this journey
and is basically saying that you can
maximize the potential for producing
something really interesting
if you're willing to drop knowing what
that interesting thing is going
to be now in the long run what that is
is basically you're generating stepping
stones
so it means that all the things that we
hope might happen in the future become
more likely but not any particular thing
because the more stepping stones we have
the more places we can get
and so it's true that the stepping stone
you end up on may not be where you
planned
to go but i would argue that like you
shouldn't be planning to go anywhere
anyway if you're going to take this
approach because what you're actually
trying to do
is just uncover stepping stones anyway
but
in aggregate because we're all
uncovering all of these stepping stones
that otherwise wouldn't even exist
we have now made possible a whole new
generation of stepping stones
some of which will be things that we
hoped would happen in the future
yeah this is what's opening up and
making those things possible
ken made it clear in in his book that
even though the world has become
saturated with objectives they're not
necessarily a bad thing modest
objectives
you know for modest goals are okay but
really ambitious
objectives that require discovery
creativity innovation
and even happiness those are the things
that we're talking about that require a
slightly different approach now
there are lots of examples of inventions
that
if you look at the intermediate stepping
stones they don't resemble the final
product at all so
kenneth gave an example of vacuum tubes
leading to computers
or microwaves being developed from radar
technology
or even the internal combustion engine
leading to aeroplane engines
and the really fascinating concept here
is that creativity could be seen as a
search
problem and that implies that we're
searching through a space of things
and this is what fascinates me because
if we are exploiting something if we're
building a bridge and we already know
how to build it
we can kind of visualize all of the
intermediate steps from now to
completion
but when we require creativity we're
actually searching through this space of
possibilities
yeah so i want to respond to something
though so the first computers were not
built with vacuum tubes
they were built with gears and machines
right and then
so the story of computing has always
been one where people wanted to do
machine based computing and they
surveyed the
componentry that they had available to
them and then they put those together at
a large scale to do
to do computing right so i view this
it's two sides of a coin
you know you've got a bunch of people
out there tinkering in garages thinking
outside the box
trying to violate the second law
painting weird things great
right and then when somebody needs to
achieve a particular thing
they look at the toolbox of stepping
stones and they put those together in
some plan planned
organized efficient large-scale way to
achieve that goal
these are not like and actually the
points made in the white paper that
these are complementary
kinds of avenues right you really have
to be doing both at the same time so it
seems like what we're really arguing
about here is
is saying that you know in western
society today we're just funneling
too much of a proportion of our
resources
onto objective pursuits and suppressing
creativity i argue we're not
really suppressing creativity to start
with but we're arguing about really a
balance of resources here
aren't we well this might be a good time
to introduce this concept of deception
so i i think if we have an objective
approach it blinds us
to the stepping stones we should
actually be taking
yeah so i think that you know keith is
really arguing for the status quo like
this
that's not a very controversial point of
view like basically you're saying that
okay we
we uh things are going fine you know we
we set objectives and this often works
well and
we should have some exploration nobody's
going to find that controversial
everything's going fine
and i think that the status quo is very
easy to argue for
because we we already have a consensus
on the status quo and we like it
we think we're very smart and that's
working well and so
you have to give some room here for the
possibility that the status quo actually
is not the best way to do things
and it's true that deception is is a
real
enemy of the status quo and it's not
recognized how pathological and serious
it is
like this idea that it looks like you're
moving in the right direction but
actually you're heading towards a brick
wall
and we could be sidestepping
this kind of brick wall much more often
if we reject the status quo
which is this confidence that we know
when the switch should happen which is i
think what really is implicit in what
keith is saying
is that okay you're recognizing and
acknowledging that yes to some extent
creativity innovation or exploration or
things that should be part of what we do
but i'm arguing that look we just give
it lip service right now
because we don't we may we may all think
those sound really good on paper
but the gatekeepers do not actually
reward you for doing that like in all
kinds of institutions that's not the way
the world actually works
this is true in publishing this is true
in grant writing
they want to know what your objective is
they want to see metrics that show that
you're moving towards that objective
it works just like some kind of naive
local optimization problem in almost all
these cases
which any expert on search would know is
just completely naive and yet we run
society as if this actually makes any
sense at all
and so somebody has to push against that
status quo just start bringing it down
so that we can actually move in
directions sometimes not because they're
causing some metric to go up but because
they're simply interesting
and they're opening up possibilities to
move in directions that will sidestep
the brick wall of deception
and actually get us to stepping stones
that are going to get us to places that
otherwise we are not going to get
and so all these gatekeepers need to
really really change their behavior
and we're not going to get there by
simply saying yeah yeah you know things
are going pretty well here like we can
anybody can go explore if they really
want to you know but like mostly things
are good because like we have people
making innovations using objectives
anyway
yeah that's the status quo things are
just going to stay the same and
and i'm arguing that look that's
actually not the best way to be doing
things
that were far the pendulum has swung far
far in the other direction
to the point where it's at this point
it's absurd like i said we're running
this like as if it's like the most naive
optimization problem
for like the most complex problems that
we have in the universe
and this just doesn't make sense at all
first of all i'm on record actually in
this show
multiple times advocating against
certain status quo for example i don't
like the one-size-fits-all
education system you know it's it's
absurd to me that life is filled with
all these niches
and instead of figuring out what
somebody would be good at and what
they're passionate about and giving them
the tool set to get to that niche we try
to funnel everybody down some uniform
you know path to college four years
whatever right so
i think i mean what i'm hearing you say
is that and i i agree that
that the pendulum has swung too far
towards objectives
uh and i and i think i said that you
know maybe it's a balance of resources
question
so i think what you're saying is the
only way to
rebalance that is to have this extreme
viewpoint you know very agenda-driven
kind of shock
shock the gatekeepers and to kind of
moving
moving away moving the pendulum towards
that that's fine
i i worry that the science doesn't
necessarily back that up and there's
this arguable point about you know
what is novelty what isn't novelty
what's interesting what's not how much
resources should we
be putting down there so i get it uh but
i think
at the end of the day we are arguing
about a balance it's like okay we have
of our resources heading towards
objectives that's a problem maybe it
needs to be
80 20 or 50 50 or who knows whatever it
is
so and that i would agree with it's not
really that when you write a grant
oh 95 of the score of the grand
readers is going towards you know can
you reach your objective but right now
it's a hundred
right it's much more of a this is the
way we do things right you want to reach
this
goal i give you money for reaching this
particular goal and that's just the way
we write grants
i mean yes and no but some of those
grants are to exploration objectives
like people do get grants
to do exploratory research what's on
everyone's mind is
wait a minute isn't novelty isn't
exploration yet just another objective
right
that you're somehow maximizing you could
argue that
kenneth is advocating for an objective
but it's the only
objective which does increase
monotonically right
because all i think the argument is is
that all of the objectives we have at
the moment create
convergent behavior not divergent
behavior and when you have a novelty
style objective
you can monotonically you know optimize
on it and it works but
i wanted to comment that i i agree that
there is a preponderance
of objectives in our society and i don't
think people realize how bad it is
whether it's in
education you know we want to
monotonically increase our grades
whether it's in science we have to have
this convergent group think because all
of the peer reviewers have to
approve something whether it's wanting
to obsessively improve gdp metrics
in our society it's absolutely pervasive
i don't think anyone in this
conversation is binary and wants it to
be one or the other
i think we just want to have a slightly
more open-ended approach
yeah yeah i mean it's true that we are
we have common ground on the idea that
this is a question of degree
i mean that that's that's clearly true
so it's not like you know keith and i
are in complete opposite ends of the
spectrum like
there's a matter of degree issue going
on here and so
to to to some extent this is actually a
political discussion and
some extent it's not actually a
scientific discussion this is about
how to affect social change in some
sense
political discussions here i mean so
so i and i and i come to this as a
scientist not qualified probably to make
a good political point here
but my anyone who's qualified to make
political points
yeah that's fair that's probably true
but so my my intuition about this
political situation
is that actually we need a really big
push we need a big we need a big push to
budge us out of our rut
and and to get us to that more
reasonable balance
whatever that may be 50 50 whatever you
want to call like i don't really think
it's actually about the percentages as
much as the types of
problems like i think it's more that
like if you're a stepping stone away
if i mean this sort of the way we put it
in the book then by all means use
objectives like there's a lot of
problems like that let's recognize that
let's not make that 50 50. let's make
that 90 10. you know like that should be
mostly just objective driven
but if you're many stepping stones away
which really means i don't have any idea
what the intervening stepping stones are
like the three the four the five the 500
that are going to lead to that thing
that i really want to see happen
then forget it then it should be the
exact opposite ratio
and so and so we should be principal now
and recognize that this is actually the
way that search works and we just
totally are not that way
and so as a political point i do think
that it's important
to push in a radical direction here and
say like you know we really need
institutional change
because like like the others are saying
that yeah it does
it is true that like in a lot of realms
like in grant writing which i'm very
familiar with
it's near 100 i mean you're right there
there's there's special programs and
things there might be some exploratory
grant program or something like that
but like you know in a conventional
program that there's a national science
foundation or something
great if you're just like this is really
interesting i don't know i can't tell
you what we're gonna accomplish but like
it's just really cool we should just
look at this
it's funny because like this is that
actually was the case with pick breeder
itself
like i i did try to get funding for pick
breeder so maybe i'm here like you know
bitter about this now this is why i'm
sitting here arguing this
but like the pick reader was just shot
down for this very reason like i have
exact
wonderful quotes from from our reviewers
about it's not clear what this is going
to accomplish
like why are you doing this we don't
really know
and and what's funny is that like i
wouldn't be sitting here having this
conversation with you guys today
we wouldn't be having this talk at all
which i which i at least think that we
would
agree is a valuable discussion to have
if we had let those gatekeepers be the
arbiters of whether this thing should
get out there or not
all right so i i kind of get what we
were saying now which is that
you know the sort of guy in the garage
the starving artist
the uh out of the box thinker there
always has been kind of a stigma
of like yeah yeah they're just kind of
over there little small things doing
their thing we can largely
ignore them right and what you're kind
of saying is that society needs to
put much more value on that process and
understand
you know the fundamental contributions
it makes towards
other progress that we may objectively
care about
let's say but so let's suppose we get to
that world like everybody goes yeah
great we
we love novelty search we still have to
allocate funding right
so when somebody comes along and says
you know what i want to
research how cheese whiz can be used
like in an agricultural setting or just
explore the properties of cheese whiz
like for that matter like do we decide
to fund that
and and how much do we allocate like
what how do we
do societal novel research but in a way
that
at least gives us some you know some
hope to progress along goals that
society cares
about you said oh we want to encourage
the artist in the garage and so on and
i think what we really want is for this
no the starving artist and the tech guy
in the garage
okay what we really want is for this
kind of treasure hunting just to be the
modus operandi
in all institutions i understand i think
that's what i said which is that
we need to understand as a society that
that type of effort needs to be
institutionalized but okay suppose we
get there how do we allocate
funds and time let me just quickly talk
about
how it works at the moment so i've
worked in the tech industry for many
years
and what i see is a tragedy of
convergent thinking so for example that
we might be building a big data platform
in some corporation
and when it's designed everyone is
saying well
i i want to make money this is my
financial year if you don't
if you don't give me some metrics by
next year then you're not allowed to do
it
and what that means is that all of the
really innovative things that we could
be building we can't even conceptualize
because we're constrained in the way
that we've designed this
system wouldn't it be great if we could
advocate for a treasure hunting approach
where
we could allocate some budget now how we
allocate that budget to your point keith
i don't know
maybe kenneth can tell us but if we just
allocated some money just for an
open-ended search just to create a
fertile environment
for search and innovation even though we
don't know where they will lead but i
guarantee you
let me say that another interesting
thing by the way kenneth is we've been
playing with gbt3
and it's this uh it's this language
model and it's it's deterministic by
default
and if you if you sample it
deterministically
you get stuck in you know like a kind of
greedy sampling
you get stuck in loops and you don't
really go anywhere
and turns out if you sample it randomly
or do a beam search
it produces better language who would
have thought it yeah so
and actually i i've had a lot of fun
with gpt 3 as well
after having joined open ai so i have
the the privilege of being able to
access it so that is that is a lot of
fun
so actually there's yeah there's several
threads going here and i also want to
acknowledge
that we lost the threat of whether
novelty is an objective that yannick
raised so
maybe we'll get back to that one but i
just want to address this
because i want to address this this
point now which which does seem really
important about how do we allocate funds
like what is the principle here
and you know the thing that i think that
that we're missing
is that we have invested enormous
amounts
in people through our through our social
investments like educating people
we're talking for decades like 30 years
like to get to a phd or something like
that
to get them to a point where they're
supposed to have intuitions right
scientific
intuitions like they're not just
supposed to be able to look at a chart
and see that oh algorithm x is actually
performing better than algorithm y
by a significant amount like people love
this significance computations right
because it's like
well i can really hammer somebody on
that like you didn't use the correct
method like to calculate significance or
something
like that doesn't take a phd to do that
the phd
allows you to have intuitions about what
are the directions that actually have
promised
and what's amazing about us using these
like relying
so much on these metrics is that it is
basically saying that we are not
allowing people to use that education
that they have
because we don't trust them after 30
years of
putting money into them of investing
them in
in our social investments thousands and
thousands of dollars maybe millions
we don't trust them to have any
intuitions at all the only thing we
trust is a significance test
and so at some point we do need to say
because this
person thinks that this path looks
interesting that we should listen to
them
now how do we know of course we don't
just say well you have a phd so we
listen to you no problem like you can do
whatever you want here's a million
dollars
that doesn't make any sense you've got
to get your head out of the clouds ken
you can't be talking like that
i think what we do need to do is start
to understand that we can have
discussions about why things are
interesting
that's the thing that i think we can
change like we
are at a level together if we have the
right background i'm not just talking
about phds either i'm talking about
experts in any field
not just phds you know whatever it may
be it could be athletes
it could be great chefs like whatever
you're talking about
like these are people who have huge
amounts of experience which gives them
the credibility to have these
discussions
and of course they should have these
discussions with their peers not with a
random person on the street
but with their peers who similarly have
that kind of a background and have been
recognized
for having that background about and
this is a very
very it's a very unsettling and
uncomfortable topic for a lot of people
but what is actually
interesting and the and it's true what
happens that enters into those
discussions is called subjectivity
and scientists just run away when they
hear about subjectivity
uh oh it's not objective like i can't
talk about it like this is getting me
scared
let's go back to some bar charts and
significance tests but come on like
ultimately
everything that's ever been done that's
interesting ultimately boiled down to
some level of subjectivity
it's just that we covered it up because
we're not allowed to talk about it
maybe we could try out like a a a little
committee an
interesting voting system
interestingness voting system it's like
you propose an idea and then anonymously
a bunch of your peers vote on whether or
not that's interesting
no that that's still convergent that's
the last thing you want
well but ken saying that we need to
trust we need to trust intuition on
what's interesting
right it's moving in a direction that i
think is interesting
i think that like the you know what you
might get
i mean maybe this is true there's a
convergent aspect to that kind of voting
type of thing voting can be dangerous
we've seen that in pick breeder too
there's there's experiments that show
you get much worse results if you sort
of vote about what's the best picture
but the idea that we can actually ask
experts to discuss what's interesting i
think is actually interesting
like it could lead to things i've heard
proposals even recently things like
before we go to the results section like
papers get through an initial filter
just based on whether the idea is
interesting
and that could be that could lead to
something different in terms of outcomes
so yeah we're able to have these
discussions about what's interesting
we can do it informally we're just
afraid to actually air
these types of things in any formal
setting but aren't you
scared that any any filtering for
interestingness
and you admit that interestingness is
subjective
how can you even set up a filter for
interestingness because that author
might think that paper is really
interesting
yeah so that relates to this idea of the
committee and the convergence and things
like that like what is actually the
right way
to maximize our
gains from elevating interestingness in
this way
and i and i agree that this should not
be the only way we evaluate things
ever of course like again we're back to
balance and degrees here
so i don't think all of society should
work this way but to the extent that we
put some resources into doing things
this way
i think that we have to think about it
as why is what is it that
makes systems like pick breeder work so
effectively
open-ended systems in general and what
it is is basically it's the connection
between one stepping stone and the next
it's like some things can lead to very
very interesting things down the road
but somebody has to make that connection
and so i think
what the issue is is that it's not a
it's not a voting issue because like the
majority is not going to make that
connection like if there's a very very
salient stepping stone for you just for
you this could change your life
like if you look at this picture of this
butterfly or something like this
it will not be true of the majority of
people and so
we will never get to follow down that
path if it's a majority rules type of
voting situation
we need you to be able to follow your
special special instinct
because that was the thing that could
change only your life that's the thing
for you
and and this is about what's interesting
this is totally subjective i mean that's
just you like butterflies
and so what we need to do i think is
create systems
where people put in are willing to put
in put a stake into things
like they're willing to put something up
to say look i'm willing to give up
some of the bonuses that i have in my
life if there's a grant system maybe
you're even willing to give up getting a
grant
to say i'm going to stick up for this
thing because this if this gets done
it's going to mean a lot to me because
it's extremely interesting and i want to
see it happen
and so we could set up a system like
that and then we know because the stakes
are high
that people are not just sort of
gratuitously or casually making these
decisions
they're making these decisions because
they matter to them and because these
stepping stones resonate with them so we
need to carefully set up the system
but i think then we can encourage people
to have these kinds of elevated
discussions
and bring out the fact that actually
this is the thing that humans are best
at it's not like just producing a bunch
of objective material
objective formal results that's not what
we're great at that computers are great
at that
they're better than us at that we have a
nose for the interesting that's how we
got this far that's how civilization
came out that's why the history of
innovation is so amazing
for the last few thousand years and so
let's elevate that
let's talk about it seriously and give
each other credit for the fact that we
can do this both on both ends both the
person
making the proposal and the person
critiquing the proposal we can talk
about what's interesting
but we just don't need it to be
consensus driven because that's not how
stepping stones work
i think that's the key point we need to
have autonomy
we spoke to max welling on friday and he
said that when his students come up with
an idea no matter how bad it is
he will zip his lips and he won't say
anything he'll let them explore it for a
month
because you just never know what's
interesting to you might not be
interesting to me
and when you have this kind of um group
thing when you all get together and
decide if something's interesting or not
there'll always be a clash because it
won't be interesting to someone else and
then that will cut the idea off
and one of the things with pick breeder
and also you mention a natural evolution
and with some of your approaches like
the poet
paper it it's all about creating a
divergent
search and in evolution and in poets
it's about
actually creating problems and solutions
at the same time
allowing you to create this beautiful
space that you can just continue to
explore
yeah exactly yeah autonomy is is a
really big part of this
and it's it's destroyed by these
committees committees and autonomy just
don't go together
you know and grants are basically run by
committee
and yeah it's it's exactly true and
something we saw very strikingly in pick
breeder
that like the reason that everything is
being discovered there in that
particular search space which is
actually a very relatively simple search
space
compared to say the space of invention
which is like
thousands of times higher dimensional
but even in this small lower dimensional
space
where those images are you know between
dozens and hundreds of dimensions in
terms of what defines them underlying
so it's a relatively low dimensional
space even in that space
like we needed to give people room to
follow their interest to their bitter
ends
without some committee intervening and
saying actually we don't think it's
interesting to go down this path sorry
about that like you should actually look
at this image instead
and we know that because there was
another project and i hate ranking on it
because i thought that was a really cool
project too it was called the living
images project
which got a lot less attention because
it was the exact opposite it was
committee driven so it makes it
really a really great contrast like it's
a really nice metaphor for the way we
run society
because the living image project
basically works like the nsf
you know they they'd show the palette of
current leading images and say okay
let's have a vote now by committee we're
going to figure out which the most
promising ones are
and it just led to a bunch of wallpaper
patterns or
probably even worse than wallpaper
patterns because they didn't even have
like symmetry it's just like kind of
pleasant looking blobs after this like
thousands and thousands of votes were
cast
and it's you know it's because like the
thing is like everything washes out when
we start
ruling by committee like we have to
allow people to follow their passions to
their extremes
and of course most of those bets won't
pay off i mean you know venture
capitalists know this
that's the nature of investing we're
talking about risk ultimately here
like risk has to be tolerated in order
to make great discoveries
so it's not like oh yeah every time
anybody's allowed to follow their
interests like great things are going to
happen
most of the time no but it's worth it to
maintain this portfolio so that we can
get them to go to their extremes and see
these amazing results
so yeah we've got to start getting rid
of these committee driven types of
systems and look at different types of
systems
which is why things like having say 5
000 grant reviewers
instead of like five but you get your
grant funded
if like two people are willing to put up
something
really big to say like yeah this is
gonna change my life
and that's enough and so that's a much
more like pick breeder-like world
than the living image type of world
crowdsource funding
you said before that your personality
naturally matches with this kind of
idea and the things you've discovered do
you
besides your personality just matching
do you make deliberate steps deliberate
attempts in your
like life to uh to implement these ideas
of
less objectives more exploration
and so on uh i think so
i i mean obviously discovering these
principles
helped me to justify being that way more
so maybe i'm more like that now
since i've been improved my ability to
make this kind of argument
maybe i've still not optimized it
completely because keith makes some good
points
here that show that we still have to
defend this
but but still i've obviously spent a lot
of time thinking about this so now just
easier for me to say well the reason we
should do this is because we've thought
about this for several years and here's
why we're going to do it this way
but yeah like something like pick
breeder is an example you know
pick breeder i had no idea what the heck
we're going to see from that
like it was like i don't think so i
don't think most
objectively comfortable researchers
would want to make a pick breeder
because it's like completely unclear
what the point is it's like the
the most sale the most alien point is
probably that it looks like a fun toy
but that's not usually why we make
things as researchers it's just because
they're a toy but that wasn't my
motivation at all
my motivation was entirely that i was
pretty sure that something interesting
was going to happen
i was like if you just release like
thousands of people
online to just explore picture space
like we're gonna see a phenomenon that
we've never seen anything like
i don't know what phenomenon it is i had
no idea but it's just gonna be so cool
and there's no question that something
like will fall out of it that'll be
valuable
because it's just so interesting and and
lo and behold like
you know my entire career it was
diverted because of doing this
and indeed like the nsf committee was
was totally turned off as you would
expect because like it's not clear what
the point is
so yeah i think i i make decisions
because i think things are interesting
and i'm not and i'm not afraid to
like i will tell people who i work with
like i think we should do this because
it's interesting i don't really know
what we're gonna find
but we need to find out and it's pretty
clear but i won't just say it like that
like that's the thing is that's the
naive the naive view
and the argument against doing what i'm
saying is to believe that that's the
whole argument somebody like
me would make like hey this is
interesting like you should follow me
just do this because it's interesting
like obviously i need to justify it to
that person
you know so like if i have somebody that
that i'm managing or advising
and i'm saying here's something i'm
proposing that we should do together
i will really try to get into the
details of why it's interesting i'm
not just gonna say it's just interesting
let's just do it but it's like look
these are
all these opportunities that this opens
up that basically create a whole new
playground
of opportunity which is arguably going
to reveal things that nobody has ever
thought about before and i'd get into
the details of why
and if i can't persuade them then i them
then i'm satisfied that i don't have a
good argument
you know because i fully believe that
that we at our education level or
experience level in our fields because
like i said you don't have to have a phd
you can be in some other field that that
we
can have an argument like this with each
other and and be completely reasonable
about it even though it's not ultimately
objective
and so i think people should have a
right to hear my case why things are
interesting and reject it
and that's totally reasonable but if i
can get it to resonate with you
and you want to follow that stepping
stone with me then i think we've made a
great connection and it's much more
exciting
than that i have a bar chart with a
significant result on it just my two
cents on communicating this because i
think
part of pushback you may get from some
people
is that if you don't if you're not
careful to make a distinction between
divergence and interestingness you know
because a lot of
divergence is not interesting like oh
look i have a a pink dot on my shoe
congratulations i don't care
right and so in the paper you kind of
make this point too which is that
yeah look not all not all divergence not
all
novelty if you will is actually
interesting and and it's an
open area of research is to defining
what exactly is
interesting or coming up with this
objective that helps to find novelty
that's actually interesting
i think that that may be some of the
nature of the pushback because we've all
been around
you know new age people that are like
look i've decorated my house and
crystals you know and i'm like yeah
like i couldn't care less right i think
novelty is the wrong word
i think kenneth said in much of his work
that a better description is being an
information accumulator
so for example you can keep crashing
into the wall in the maze but eventually
you know what what if i could actually
do something more interesting in my
policy and in order to do that i would
need to
accumulate useful information and it
works really well because even in
evolution there seems to be an
arrow of complexity that goes through
the evolution of life on this planet
and being able to breathe air and being
able to
see photons of light being able to climb
trees
all of these things help us exploit our
environment more effectively
yeah but i want to point out there's way
too much context shifting both in the
paper and in the book
jumping back and forth between
information versus
interestingness versus novelty versus
complexity
you know that these are not the same
thing and and there there's there's
actually are examples in both the book
and the paper
of context shifting i mean the sort of
logical fallacy of starting off in one
context and then sort of
magically alighting over to like a
different one so
these are not the same concepts and and
i think the one that actually will
resonate with more people is
interestingness because tons of
information is flat out boring
okay like the exact precise trajectory
of a missile
really not excited with that right or
what you ate today for lunch
you may be highlighting useful strategic
angle here i'll acknowledge that how how
do you effectively
communicate these points and i do think
that
it's worth thinking about that like the
book is an attempt to do that
and it's true that some people are are
turned off by it so maybe it could be
more effective i have to agree with that
and but i don't think i think what
you're calling context shifting for
me was an attempt to
uh provide multiple different angles of
argument
for to support this so like when tim
mentions
information accumulation which i'm
really uh flattered that i mean do you
remember all these things i've said so
that's
certainly i'm happy to hear you making
those arguments because these are these
are arguments that i put out
like these are just different angles of
attack from making the argument
for divergent non-objective type of
search and the information accumulation
i think is really interesting and it's
complementary in my view
to arguments about divergence and
interestingness and so forth
and not like some kind of you know sort
of dishonest uh
subtle shifting uh trying to move the
ball around
but just trying to give lots of
different arguments and and the reason
we wrote the book that way
was the book was really meant to be a
weapon it's because
people who uh are the gatekeepers
who are in charge of the flows of funds
that control
whether certain things get done or don't
get done are generally very
objectively driven and i wanted to give
people
who are trying to satisfy those
gatekeepers
as many possible arguments as they could
get and they could choose and pick and
choose from those arguments and that's
why the book is not written
in necessarily the most crowd-pleasing
way it's more like
look i'm just going to put out here all
of the arguments that we can think of
and you're going to be able to use them
and so i understand that for some people
it's just a turn off from the start
so it's really this is an honest this is
sort of an honest
outpouring outpouring of my thoughts
about this
without selling out and just trying to
make something for public appeal
which is something that we considered i
mean we went through literary agents and
things that had all kinds of suggestions
for watering this down so it'll appeal
more
but then i just started to feel like it
was turning into a sellout
and so that's why it's this weird
mishmash of like self-help like combined
with like empirical scientific arguments
you're like what kind of book is this
and who is this for
and it's not really for anything in
particular it's just meant to be a
weapon
i i get it but by the way i'm not
suggesting that you dull the weapon i'm
suggesting that it be sharpened because
for at least some people out there like
myself i'm not i'm totally not opposed
to the idea of the importance of you
know interestingness
but i really can't abide
sort of illogical arguments and so when
when i see things that don't logically
follow
non-sequitur context shift you know
appeal to emotion
you know begging the question et cetera
et cetera to me it becomes like
less effective and so i understand it's
a balance you know you're trying to
trying to create a weapon and you know
there's a bell curve out there along
every single
personality attribute and and whatnot
i get it i'm suggesting that a focus on
interestingness
alone is a very sharp kind of tool to
that
just to that point because that that is
a good point actually i think that
interestingness really is central here
it's a very important part of this
and it comes up a lot in these kind of
discussions i mean
it's related to like how you what should
guide divergent type of search processes
i mean you're following a gradient but
it's not the gradient of objective
improvement so what gradient
is it and it's true that i think the
gradient of interestingness
is one is probably the best expression
of like the ideal divergent search
but then you know you get to this
problem that like i don't know how to
formalize interestingness
and so it it leaves it a little bit a
little bit
less concrete than what we have in like
normal machine learning obviously
we know exactly what gradient we're
following and so what you get to then
are proxies for interestingness
and so things like novelty you know the
good thing about novelty
is that it's true that not everything
that's novel is interesting
but just about everything that's
interesting is novel and so
it's like a pretty good like rough
heuristic
for getting to see some of what in a
true
interestingness driven search would
reveal which would be even more powerful
now something like pick breeder is much
more kind of like close to like actually
following gradients of interestingness
because it's human beings that are
making the decision and humans arguably
make decisions on what's interesting
when they look at pictures but we all
have different definitions implicitly
about what is interesting
which makes it even more interesting i
mean that's why more stepping stones for
you
are different than the stepping stones
that i would follow which is why it ends
up being divergent
but it's very hard to formalize this
right it could be even ai complete
like to really get interestingness in
that sense like to be
in it just run completely autonomously
in a computer and so we need to look for
proxies and also
we also need to recognize that
interestingness is a subjective concept
and therefore we really never will
formalize it in an objective way
so we have to accept some degree of
subjectivity as we try to formalize
these sort of gradients of
interestingness
and that sort of from the algorithmic
perspective what we should argue about
is like what level of formalization is
acceptable here
that is likely to lead to an unfolding
process that's really cool in the long
run
and it's okay that it's partly
subjective could we formalize what it
might look like because
being very naive the helicopter view is
that we want to have
we definitely don't want convergent
systems we want to have divergent
systems that are
rich in information and also we don't
want to have
shortcuts you mentioned some perverse
incentives like for example in
in india they paid a ransom didn't they
if you handed in dead snakes but that
just led to snake farms
and a similar thing in hanoi with the
rats people started breeding rats and it
you know that the actual opposite of of
what you wanted to happen happened
so we don't want to have those shortcuts
we don't want to have those perverse
incentives
so if i did design such a system and i
had to design
some measure of interestingness or
information accumulation
and i analyzed this system what things
would i be looking for as a measure of
success
yeah so i think we have to distinguish
between systems with humans in the loop
or not
because so which one are we because i
think with humans in the loop
we we might we might trust to some
extent
that like there's a human brain involved
so that helps a lot this is fascinating
we have quite a technical audience so we
can we can take the level up about one
step
so it was using these cppns these
compositional pattern producing network
and with neat
that was a genetic algorithm for
evolving the weights and topologies of a
neural network but in
pick breeder it was an entirely human
supervised process so presumably
you did know how to uh cross over two
networks but it was supervised by the
humans every single step of the way
yeah yeah it i mean part of need is in
pick breeders
the neat proceeds pick reader like so so
one of the things that allows pick
breeder to do what it does is the fact
that the networks are becoming more
complex as the breeding process
goes forward because there's a neat like
algorithm under the hood
except as you say there's a big
exception which is yeah the selection
decisions are not being made by neat
they're being made by people
so so yeah it's it's like a hybrid of
people in need
together it brings out an interesting no
pun intended
interesting thing in in that i don't
know what your opinion on on
trolls and trolling is but i just think
of trolls as people that
do things primarily because they're
interesting to them
and they almost shine no effort to
just do something interesting and i'm
just i'm just wondering
what if a group of trolls decide to
troll pick breeder
would they deliberately do
non-interesting things
is like or or because that would defeat
their purpose
or would they do interesting things and
then that would you know
defeat their purpose as well it it's
like you've made the perfect system
against trolls
that's i had not thought of the
connection with trolls that's true
trolls or trolls have a sort of instinct
for interestingness of their own
and and it it can actually lead to
things that that we wouldn't otherwise
see or think
so so trolls have a value trolls and
pick breeder is an interesting question
they you know if somebody was
adversarial towards pick breeder like a
really bad troll
like really trying to to wreck it or
something i guess they could really try
to just publish all kinds of garbage i
mean i guess that's what you would do
but it's not going to be that effective
you know because the system
is designed basically to try to raise
things up that people find
interesting so people just aren't going
to respond to that kind of stuff
if you had a troll army i do think you
could probably wreck pick breeder
it's thousands of people and then they
sort of work together
to try to vote up things elevate things
that are just horrible
yeah it would wash out the stuff that
we're trying to elevate so people could
find
like they could mislabel things
intentionally like we people put
keywords so if you found a face you
could write face
well if they called it like a dog i mean
it's gonna mess things up
so yeah i think i think it with enough
effort we could screw the whole thing up
but most likely like one troll is
totally harmless like this stuff would
just never be
would never rise up and we wouldn't see
it and then there's the other kind of
troll
which is somebody who just has different
interests he just says like
all these images you know there's skulls
in these cars this is this is not the
kind of thing that i think is cool i
think like these
weird line patterns or something there
should be a lot more of those
that is healthy i think that's great you
know have that have that divergent
branch of the tree of life
and let's reveal it there were people
like that there was this guy
robert that was his screen name because
he was so memorable because he created
thousands of images an unbelievable
amount of work
involved but he was doing these line
studies like he was trying to get as
straight a line as possible you know
like with the activation functions in
these cppns it's kind of hard to get
things that are just straight
so this guy was really obsessed with
like squares that have real corners you
know 90 degree angles
like just told these whole giant studies
and it's like just totally different for
what everybody else is doing
but it's great because like like
branching off of those things leads to a
completely different world and change
my view of what a cppn or even a neural
network is
you know because once you get into those
spaces with these sharp angles and
straight lines
you st you know people were saying well
there's this like pick breeder style
it's kind of this like
curvy like kind of blobby looking kind
of style that like everything has
it's actually not true thanks to this
troll we know
that you just need to break into this
part of the space and you've got a very
sharp well-defined kind of style
so yes trolls if you call that a troll i
think it's it can be useful
and interesting that's super awesome so
i i do want to get back to though
to the kind of it seems to all hinge on
very much kind of a definition of
interestingness and how
what or what proxy you choose for tim
mentioned for example this
if you crash into a wall repeatedly you
might
once go around it but then again you
know if you crash into the wall
the 22nd time that's novel to crashing
into the wall the 21st time and maybe
the 23rd time the world is suddenly
going to open up you don't know right as
long as you don't define
some notion of novelty everything is
novel
right yeah that's true yeah this is uh
this is an issue uh that ultimately
these algorithms depend on some
definition of interestingness and even
beyond algorithms then like if i'm if if
we're advocating doing things like this
in the real world
gatekeepers like eventually confront
this issue of like yeah the open maze
like just
running off into oblivion what's the
point of that this has to do with
notions of open-endedness and like what
makes them work
and it's true that you do not you do not
have a successful open-ended system
just by virtue of the fact that it's
open there has to be some constraint
there's still
some constraint because we have finite
resources
in terms of space and time like if we
had infinite resources which we don't
but hypothetically
i don't think this would be a problem we
would literally just collect every
branch of everything
forever and we have infinite space and
time and so we'll just do it and
everything great would be revealed
of course most things that we see would
be junk but who cares we get everything
great too
but we have finite resources so we have
to have constraints
so and then that leads to well what are
what are the constraints
like a lot of the time when we talk
about these things like people think of
it more in terms of like
expressing what i like like what do we
actually want i think of it more like
well we need to express what we don't
want because everything else is fine
let's see all the stuff that if it's
something if it's not something i don't
want
it could be really useful and in fact i
have a problem even with things i don't
want
because they might be stepping stones to
things i do want
so being too too careful about this in
some sense
could actually wreck the process but
ultimately
there are some things we have to exclude
we cannot afford to look at everything
that's just going to be random search
and so what should we exclude and it
goes back to notions of interestingness
and absolutely we should we should
really dig into this
and i mean i don't know on the show we
can do it in the show but just in
general it's very important for the
field to dig into
what does it mean to be interesting and
you know i think evolution is somewhat
instructive
because evolution does have some
constraints and evolution is an
incredible open-ended process
like the process that produced all of
living nature which is
as i like to say literally biblical in
terms of what it's
accomplished and so you can look at it
and and see that
clearly it does have some constraints
like there are some lineages
that are not followed they fail and
and and yet like if you look at the the
reasons for that
mapping that to like the word
interesting is a pretty large
distance you know like this idea of
survive and reproduce
and then interestingness it's not
completely clear that those are like
directly connected to each other and yet
it seems
perfectly good at finding things that
are interesting like i'd argue
everything's interesting in nature
that could just be me but that sort of
illustrates to me one
one thing here is that you don't have to
be perfect about this
like if you can have a reasonable
constraint and we can talk about what
that means
like what is reasonable there's a lot of
thought that we can have behind that
but you can do pretty well here like it
doesn't have to be perfect
we don't have to really really formalize
the notion of interesting down to like
the last iota of information because we
don't really know
but as long as it's reasonable like
something like survive and reproduce can
be incredible in terms of the power
because of the power of divergence and
the fact that it's pruning out enough
junk that it's going to produce mostly
cool stuff
so i'm glad you made this point because
i remember from the book it
brought up this example of imagine a you
know a world in which there was no
selection pressure like uh and all
organisms survived like how amazing that
would be
and my thought was it wouldn't be
interesting at all because it'd just be
a massive gray goo
consisting of like nearly identical
bacteria that reproduce at the
fastest conceivable rate like if you
don't have that minimal selection
you actually don't end up with an
interesting world it's kind of like
white noise is not interesting and
neither is a constant number
like something in between those two is
interesting
yeah yeah i mean that was meant to be a
thought experiment in the book
which we called it the gentle earth
because everybody gets to have a baby no
matter what
so it's like yeah you don't need to have
sexual organs because god will make a
baby for you
in this hypothetical thought experiment
that's right and it's true that like
yeah the vast majority of the world
would be grey goo
i'm totally with you on that but uh what
what i thought was interesting about the
thought experiment
is that we'd still have all the cool
stuff we have today there would be
humans
as long as we had the same mutation
distribution so it's like you know
that's part of the distribution of
of mutations that happen because it did
happen and so those paths would be
followed in addition to the fact that
99.99999
of those pads are just goo inert blobs
flying on the ground
and that is just weird to think about
you know because it shows that like
our existence is not entirely explained
by selection
like part of it is actually about the
structure the a priori structure of the
search space
that this universe has defined for us
that we have exploited through evolution
and i find that very intriguing i was
going to ask about that in the relation
of cppns because presumably there is a
kind of prior in in the
the the activation functions and so on
but but coming back to evolution
you said a really interesting thing one
of the things that concerns me is that
in a way it's depressing
that you can't shortcut innovation and
discovery
there's this huge array of stepping
stones that you need to find and
in evolution if we wanted to turn the
clock back you made this
thought experiment in your book let's
say you wanted to pick all of the single
cell organisms and you wanted to breed
an einstein
so you're just going to start from the
very beginning and you're just going to
breed all of these things together and
none of the intermediate stepping stones
look anything like
intelligence actually we're trying to
create artificial general intelligence
at the moment and probably
none of the intermediate stepping stones
that we see now will in any way resemble
artificial general intelligence
and the depressing reality is that it is
a search problem
and is it is it safe to say that
when we talk about evolution what we
actually want is maximal
exploitation of our environment because
there's a trade-off between exploration
and exploitation
and we talk about wanting
interestingness or novelty or whatever
it is but
isn't that just a proxy for exploitation
of our environment that is
an interpretation of what makes
evolution powerful
that might be even just thought of as
like a restatement of different ways of
saying like what's powerful about
evolution
like exploitation of the environment or
the satisfaction of a minimal criterion
but but the thing that's missing from
that that i think you have to remember
is that we are part of the environment
so like there's more to it than just
that like that maybe is one of the
critical elements
that is to get to einstein there's that
objective paradox
and so you can't get the einstein by
trying to exploit the environment but
it's like not the only thing that you
need
to get there because there's these other
principles like the fact that we are
part of the environment
ourselves the environment is not a
static thing the environment is us
and so we are creating the opportunities
that can lead to einstein it's like the
trees and the giraffes you can't have
giraffes if you don't have trees
you can't have einstein if you don't
have other people to uh appreciate and
interact with einstein
and so this there's a whole set of
principles
that need to be in place to be able to
get to something like einstein through
an open-ended process
and i would argue that we still we still
don't know
uh what all of them are like this is an
open area of research
do you find it depressing though that
someone from the future
can come into his or her time machine
and come and talk to us today
and there are all these incredible
inventions that have been invented in
his or her time
and this person wants to imbue us with
all of these cool ideas
and it's kind of depressing that we
can't take any shortcuts
ah yeah that's yeah there's plenty of
shortcuts
many yeah if you knew where where you
would you know where you'd be going
i think this brings us back to this to
this notion of
of what if what if we have an objective
but maybe it's far away like how do we
reach it and that
that actually brings me to two
algorithms of yours or
where you've been involved that
fascinate me it's so the big one is go
explore and that's as i see it
part built on on map elites so
and it just brief for people who don't
know if and correct me if i'm wrong
basically what map elites does it sort
of subdivides
a search space into cells and then
what you want to do is you for each cell
you kind of want to keep the most
promising candidate around so you want
to keep the most promising
neural network for the small learning
rate and then one for the medium
learning rate and one for the large
and then you can kind of cross over
you can you can take some change them
and if they happen to end up in another
cell and get better than
the thing that's there you replace them
and so on so
your goal is to build up this almost
kind of population
but that's separated by force
and then go explore it's it's kind of it
was so amazing right everyone was trying
to solve montezuma's revenge
and everyone's like yeah we almost can
do level one
and then you know you come along and
it's like boom we solve the game
done bye and but so my my question there
there would be that it seems like
you have an algorithm for for general
exploration
but there seems so much domain knowledge
in that right so the way you subdivide
this parameter space in map elites
or the way that you assign these
different cells to explore in go explore
and so on isn't that almost isn't that
almost the same as tim
saying there's someone from the future
that sort of know what
knows what to do and you're almost kind
of building that knowledge
into the algorithm but you're sort of
hiding
that you do that right it's the question
is could you do the same thing
for for when you don't know the stepping
stones because in
in go explore you do yeah yeah that's
so that's that's a great question this
is getting into
into the weeds of the research really
where
like it is sort of at the cutting edge
with these types of algorithms
including like map elites which which
just to acknowledge
is not something that that i was
involved in creating although it's it's
in this area
sorry of these novelty i mean it's it's
one of these quality diversity
algorithms that was originally inspired
by novelty search so definitely it's
definitely in the right category
and a beautiful algorithm also by the
way but yeah when you start to talk
about how to subdivide the space
or in novelty search how do you measure
the distance between two things for for
the purposes
of maintaining divergence or diversity
you end up or or yeah and go explore how
you divide up the cells
you end up making a decision as a human
being
which is based on sort of domain
knowledge that's true
and from the like sort of high
aspirations of machine learning we would
rather not have to make decisions like
this there's fewer hyper parameters
and it seems it seems sort of sad that
we have to do that as humans
and so i think that in this in this
field i mean if you want to call this a
field
and like map elites would be in sort of
like the field of quality diversity
that's sort of what they're calling
these kind of algorithms or novel
searches local competition there's like
a bunch like this
that do take into account some objective
notions as well sort of as keith alluded
early on like that
like yeah we can combine these notions
of course there's a degree
of degree and quality diversity sort of
about that and but then we get to this
issue
even in the most pure form of like just
novelty search we don't even have a
notion of quality of
yeah what is what does it mean for two
things to be interestingly different
and where do we draw those dividing
lines and how should the distances be
measured
and it is currently an active area of
exploration
even in just reinforcement learning you
know it's like curiosity driven search
you have to make these kind of
determinations
of like what is different from what to a
sufficient degree to be
deemed novel in some way and there are
people trying to make completely generic
measures of that it's interesting to do
that uh to try to do it
in a completely generic way the enhanced
poet has a little bit of
a flavor of that because it has this
special measure which is based on like
how like a new environment re-ranks the
quality ratings of agents
so you might say well that could
actually be applied in many different
domains
but then you could argue about like that
there's some domains where that might
not make sense and so forth i mean we're
getting into the weeds but
but the thing is that i think it's a
fruitful area to look at how generic can
we get
and get away from like having to have
this kind of human insight into the
domain
but i also think it's not terrible if we
do have to have some human insight into
the domain it's not the end of the world
like if
if having human insight into the domain
did lead us to create an artificial
einstein
is anybody gonna complain i mean it
doesn't really matter
so at some level it's okay as long as
the results are really awesome
yeah since we got onto this topic of
kind of distance metrics
i wanted to ask one more technical
question then i'll give it back to you
in it because this is something that
kind of
annoyed me in the paper that i wanted to
ask about for those who haven't read the
paper
just for the benefit of the recording
keith is talking about abandoning
objectives
evolution through the search for novelty
alone
by joel lemon and kenneth stanley in
2011.
so in the maze search you know it starts
off by we're going to run a network and
it gets to some location in the maze and
the way in which we're going to measure
novelty is compare its final location
to the kind of archive of uh of
locations that we've that we stored
right and then and then you talk about
refinements to that maybe if we sampled
the path you know some k number
of times and then we looked at i think
was the l2 norm you know between those
sort of that trajectory and all other
trajectories
okay good then we get to the the uh the
bipedal
kind of walker which was the second case
in there and it immediately starts off
by saying
yeah we've got to do the the sampling
because you know the final location is
just not really
relevant to the way it was walking which
was kind of
hand wavy to me and then it makes this
comment that that the metric has no
knowledge of the distance in which it
it walked but if you look right up above
it where the formula is defined
it's xk minus x0 i.e the origin
squared so in fact it automatically has
built in the distance from the origin
like in the actual you know thing which
is being compared
right so in other words points that are
further away from the origin
are naturally going to have a larger
weight in the l2 metric when you start
comparing you know paths
i guess my comments are one did i
misunderstand anything there and two
like
the hand waviness i think is really more
just a function that this is a new area
of research and so tying back into what
you and yannick were talking about is
we have a long way to go as as a
scientific body of knowledge to really
think about these
novelty you know measures and and
interestingness measures as we've kind
of been talking about
yeah so i think that the there is an
issue
about the the diversity measure or
what we we call the behavior
characterization and with novelty search
or the bc like how we characterize
behavior there's some vector that
characterizes
what this thing did and it could be a
trajectory of points it
it followed through or something like
that and and
the degree to which it aligns with what
you're interested in
which actually could be something that
we call an objective even
and it's true that if it's completely
orthogonal
to your interests you probably won't
like what you get
so like i was thinking of like say in
the maze like if there's a robot in a
maze
and the robot has a light on its head
that can flash at sort of any arbitrary
time
like if we just like measured novelty
based on the flashing pattern of the
light and just ignored where the robot
went
like and we actually care about it
getting through the maze like clearly
this is a really bad idea and completely
stupid
and so so indeed there is like a hand
waviness
to to that i mean if if that's how you
want to kind of characterize it
or intuition intuition or human
intelligence or human insight
to to understand how our notions of
novelty align with the interests that we
actually have in the problem
we've noticed that like you can
sometimes have
an orthogonal sort of non-aligned uh
form of measure at the same time as an
aligned form of measure and that
actually might even work better
because of this problem that like
sometimes the stepping stones to things
that you like are actually things that
you don't like and so there's actually a
pretty complicated problem
and there's not an easy answer to it but
i think that
the ultimate thing is that you just have
to acknowledge
that that we have not eliminated the
need for us to define something
like in the objective world you
basically have to define the metric that
sort of like measures how close you're
getting to the objective
in the novelty world you have to define
this novelty metric
and then you still have to define
something i would argue though
it's not a super terrible obstacle
because
it doesn't have to be perfect that's one
of the points the paper was trying to
make like
that like you can there's a whole
variety of these behavior
characterizations that all still work
basically the same these have to be
reasonably aligned
yeah you made that point like in my
opinion very clearly with the
uh showing how if you divide up the maze
into a grid
that you just need like a 4x4 grid or
something to
to work well you know in other words you
didn't need a high resolution grid i
think that kind of makes the point that
the that the novelty metric itself can
be quite
loose in a sense it just has to be
minimally
good this paper is the the abandoning
objectives paper where we figure out the
policy for this
robot using neat and amaze is a
wonderful example of something that has
deception
so here for example if the objective was
monotonically improving on the distance
to the final objective then this would
be deception it would get stuck in a
basin of attraction here
but the thing i found a little bit
strange is it almost seems like cheating
knowing the distance to the final
objective
and optimizing on that but i suppose
there's not really much else you could
use
because otherwise you'd have to do some
kind of reward shaping to find out what
an intermediate a good position might
look like
yeah it's one thing that's really
important about it is that it's
really meant to be metaphorical and so
it's like
like the whole maze problem doesn't
doesn't make any sense if you if you're
thinking of it as something other than a
metaphor like if you take it literally
it's not like a really great example of
anything but what it's supposed to be
metaphorical in just the sense that
search problems generally have this
property that we really don't know like
the right kind of shaping measure
so we are in this kind of room with
walls and like there are these dead ends
we don't know where they are in general
the maze is different that you can see
them
literally but but the real truth is that
we don't even know like you we could we
actually have tried this
you know what the path is through the
maze so you could just define the
reward function such that it rewards you
higher as you follow the actual correct
path through the maze
of course this breaks the metaphor
because the whole point is like in
general you wouldn't know the right path
through the search space if you did you
don't have any problems
but what's interesting that is even if
you knew the path through the maze
it still will work worse because there's
more to the deception than just
the structure of the maze that's what's
interesting here there's other
subtleties that are below the level at
which we can visually perceive them
because this is about the search base of
neural networks this is the search base
is not
actually mazes the search space is the
underlying neural representations
and we really don't understand that did
you often make the assertion
that all ambitious objectives have
deception
could you quantify why that is
yeah that's an assertion that's trying
to make the argument that pip breeder
connects to real life
because i think that the inclination if
i make this argument about this
objective paradox which is basically
that
following an objective can be an
impediment to achieving it and if i
base that argument on observations of
pick breeder which is that
in almost every case the images that
were discovered by pick breeder users
were discovered by people who were not
trying to discover them
and that is because of deception if i
make that argument
then for many people the first
inclination is to reject it
on the basis that hey pick breeder's not
real life you're just
exaggerating the implications here
there's something special about this
pick breeder system
so for me to extend this argument
outside of pick breeder i have to make a
strong argument
that pick reader actually is like real
life and and i do think it is
and the reason that i think it is is
because pick reader is actually much
much simpler than real life
like in pick reader if you take any
arbitrary image like the skull
and you say okay well how would i get
there from scratch like
we don't really know how to get there
from scratch we don't know what the
stepping stones are like
at all i mean one set of stepping stones
are now known because someone did
discover the skull and
they happen to be things like a doughnut
there's a doughnut that you have to go
through
to get to the skull there may be other
trajectories also there's infinite
trajectories through search space so
that may not be the only one
but the point is if it's a
counterintuitive one and so
this means that like anybody who's just
saying like an expert on skulls who's
saying like how close are we to a skull
is not going to accept those stepping
stones like those metric
that metric of improvement of like how
close are we to a skull is not the right
one
for following that trajectory through
the search space and my argument is
that's the way of course all hard
problems are that's basically the
definition of a hard problem
like if you knew what the stepping
stones were it wouldn't be hard we would
just follow the stepping stones of
course
and not only that but like pick reader
is a joke in terms
of its complexity compared to the real
world if this
situation is coming up in pick breeder
where we're talking about
dozens or hundreds of dimensions maximum
can you imagine real world search spaces
which are like millions of dimensions
like extreme complexity
they're going to be like orders of
magnitude
more complex in other words there are
orders of magnitude more of these
deceptive stepping stones
inside of that trajectory towards that
thing that we hope to finally find
i would push back on a couple things
there one is you know pick breeder is a
particular tool set
you know this is generative networks
right whereas if i was a person and i
wanted to create an image of the skull i
would use
photoshop and i would get it done in an
hour and it would be like much more
resemblance of a skull right if i was a
egyptian pharaoh and i wanted to build
the great pyramid which hopefully we all
agree are
great achievements i do it with a simple
process of stacking you know
stones one on top of the other with a
simple set of like generalizable tools
so the fact
is that like in real life in the real
world humans do very well by applying
simple sets of tools in large scale plan
projects to achieve great things but but
the difference is
if we already conceptualize if we
already know what it is
we know what the pyramid is that's
exploitation it's not exploration
my point is those are still great things
so look but those are still great things
getting to the moon building a pyramid
building the hoover dam all these things
were great accomplishments
and they were planned and so that's like
the title
i understand which is i've been trying
to make this point from the beginning
that science and engineering are two
sides of a coin
right and we progress by by utilizing
both
it's not a binary either or thing you
know
okay look yeah let me take that on that
this this that's a good that's a good
thing to try to argue about
so i think that what what's happening
there is you're not really letting me
use pic breeder as a metaphor
it's just a metaphor like the skull is
is not the point is not that like
the skull is something that artists
would or would not would not find hard
or like artists don't know how to draw a
skull
i mean it's nothing to do with that at
all the skull is just a metaphor for
something that we don't know how to get
to
we don't know what the steps are to get
to the skull in pick reader space indeed
i'm not talking about human space with a
canvas and a pencil
now one interesting thing though is that
most people can't draw a skull
most people are not going to draw a
skull even close to as good as that
skull
so indeed pick breeder is actually
allowing people to get to points in
picture space that they couldn't get to
normally
other than maybe some expert artists
that actually do have that skill
but that's not that's a side point
though the main point is this is just a
metaphor for so complex search spaces in
general where we don't know what the
stepping stones are that's all it's
about
it has nothing to do with like whether
somebody might be able to draw a skull
or not
and so we are really in a in a situation
like with something like curing cancer
it is like the skull like you can't just
sit down with your canvas and just say
oh well let's just put this let's just
put the pieces together and just do this
like we don't know what the heck the
pieces are at all so there's a whole
bunch of discoveries that need to be
made that haven't been made yet
we don't even know who's going to make
those discoveries they may not even be
biologists we have no idea
and so like we are in this situation
where
like if you just follow the path of
things that seem like they're on the
path to curing cancer
you're probably not going to cure cancer
i think i can confidently say that this
is why we need exploratory research
funded by the nih
and the nih knows that we can't just
only fund things which look like
hey we've improved this outcome by two
percent unlike the death rate for this
particular kind of cancer
that is not going to lead to the
ultimate cure for cancer any more than
hey this looks two percent more like a
skull so let's just go in this direction
because that's totally not the right
path for getting to a skull
you're going to go to a deceptive dead
end for sure if you follow that kind of
path
so this is a completely metaphorical
argument you need to take it as that
there's it's going with two sides which
is we need both
discovery and exploitation kind of like
in our multi-armed bandit talk like for
example
there's a quote made in the uh white
paper that said
yet its appeal is that it rejects the
misleading intuition that objectives
are an essential means to discovery i
don't know people who think
objectives are a means to discovery they
think exploration is a means to
discovery they think objectives
are a means to engineering building
accomplishment refinement
optimization right which is which is
perhaps even
the bulk of what needs to be done like
if i have 10 000 people that need to be
housed
i don't need to discover a new type of
house i need to go build houses
yeah but but that that is engineering
right so i don't think anyone but
kenneth has made
it clear that objectives work really
well for exploiting knowledge we already
have
whereas they are incredibly bad for
discovering new knowledge
as kenneth just said so eloquently that
there's a universe
of possibilities and knowledge out there
waiting to be discovered
and we can only discover them by
searching through
this huge space of possibilities
yeah and the tools to do that searching
requires
optimization and exploitation to perfect
them it's it's
it's a dual there's a dual process here
well
i mean of course our enlightened friends
in the scientific community will agree
with you and give lip service to
exploration there's no question about
that
i just think that the the behavior of
people does not align
with the things that you're saying that
they say like that they would
acknowledge that exploration is
important
when we accept scientific papers it's
almost always because something improved
objectively
you can talk about exploration all day
but that's the way the community
actually operates
so there's some disconnect here between
sort of like these sort of high-minded
types of discussion about how
exploration is great
and the actual way people operate in
almost all fields
except maybe in art art is interesting
because i think it can actually be
instructive for us in our field
but the other thing is that if we think
about objectives or exploration
in terms of how like say machine
learning researchers talk about it
they don't really mean it in the way
that i'm talking about like when they
talk about explanation you're just
talking about when you take
random steps when you're not actually
following the objective gradient
like there's nothing random about
following a gradient of novelty or
interestingness
this is a totally different thing and
this is not the kind of thing they're
talking about they're like talking about
is sort of like
the the exploration part is kind of like
a throwaway part of the algorithm
it's just like you do something stupid
the smart parts are the parts you're
actually going towards the objective
so i'm saying we got to flip this
completely like the smart part
is the exploration the dumb part is the
objective part
because it's freaking easy there's
nothing really insightful or interesting
about just doing objective optimization
yeah we've got plenty of good algorithms
for doing that and it's not
counter-intuitive at all it totally
makes sense but it's not going to get us
hardly anywhere interesting whatsoever
so like giving it a lot of lip service
and credit and saying look how important
objective optimization is we should all
be like really congratulating ourselves
i think it's just setting us in the
wrong direction because it's not the
thing we need to concentrate on to
change the way that the community is
moving
if we want to have disruptive change
we've got to start talking about
what does exploration really mean how do
we actually implement it in real life
and not just talk about it
i wouldn't disagree with that i think
it's just important to maintain the
connection that was made in the white
paper which is
you know uh maybe it's most efficient to
take the most promising results from
novelty search and further optimize them
based on an objective function
i think that's a totally you know sort
of great starting point for me
personally
i mean i want to give credit to that
like i mean a lot of people have that
intuition
just before you i don't want to shoot
down everything you're saying like it's
true that at some point when we meet in
the middle
there will be a role for objective
optimization
still i mean that's true especially when
you're just a stepping stone away
it's not as simple as you just switch
when it's time because the whole problem
is we don't know when it's time
and that that's the problem like that's
why i think only visionaries really
understand when it's time to switch
and that's sort of like the you know
visionaries are often characterized as
people who think about
several stepping stones away like a
genius it's like
i can see off on the horizon how do i
get to this thing that nobody else knows
how to get to
i don't think anybody can do that nobody
knows that what a visionary is is
somebody
who realizes that suddenly has something
has snapped into view and the rest of us
didn't
and then it's time to make the switch
but that takes real insight
like that's like steve jobs seeing you
know that we can get from like the ipod
to the iphone
like that's not everybody just okay now
we're in the valence let's start doing
optimization
like that's really tricky i wanted to
touch on
just in in closing there are different
views so there are schools of thought in
the machine learning world right there's
compute driven versus knowledge
based and model driven versus data
driven and symbolic or statistical and
white box or black box and
generative or discriminative and you're
coming at this from a really interesting
angle which is
you're an advocate of neural networks
and and you think that we need to have a
search-based paradigm to find things
so do you think a search approach could
lead to
intelligence um yeah i think that it is
an important
element uh it may not be an either or
situation
where it's just like there's just one
paradigm that's the paradigm
but i do believe that search
as you're putting it which really means
like like searching for the
ai as opposed to just constructing the
eye by hand i guess you could say
which is like you know my colleague and
friend jeff cloon calls these ai
generating algorithms or aigas like
algorithms that generate ais instead of
actually making the a we make the
algorithm to generate the a
i totally think that that's important
and
that you know we are that we ourselves
as humans with human intelligence are
the product of a process like this like
there's
there's an outer loop that explains our
existence
which is it not itself a human level
intelligence you know it's this
evolutionary algorithm
which is still not fully understood if
it was we would just program it to the
computer and then we'd get human brains
to come out and we don't know how to do
that
but it's this this outer loop that it's
an open-ended process
because it also produces things like
photosynthesis or the flight of birds
like it's not just designed to produce
intelligence
it's an open-ended algorithm and it's
because of the fact that it gets around
deception that it can get
so so far down the tree of search to
something like us which is just an
extreme level of complexity astronomical
that this is probably an important
element but not the only element
like these other kinds of progress that
are happening in the field
should enter into it and dovetail i
think with
stuff like that as opposed to like we're
at odds with each other in partisan
camps or something like that
and so i see these different stepping
stones
being brought together just as they
often are in the history of invention
you take an airplane and you take an
engine and eventually you get a
spaceship
and i think you know the history of
engines and the history of the
aerodynamics which goes back to people
who are making bicycles
are different trajectories but they
eventually are brought together by
people like the wright brothers
and this can happen here too and so
that's what i expect to happen if we
ever do get that far
to like human level stuff well professor
kenneth stanley
thank you very much for joining us this
evening it's been an absolute pleasure
thank you that was a great discussion
yeah thank you so much really appreciate
it it was an honor
amazing i've been excited about this for
literally months so it's fine i can i
can attach to that
i forced keith to read your book in june
uh poor keith but but thank you i really
appreciate everybody's i appreciate
everybody's input here this was this was
a great time it's one of my favorite
experiences
of any show so thanks for having me on
it's really an honor to be here
remember to like comment and subscribe
we love reading your comments and we'll
see you back
next week